e
e e
morning everyone if you would please
rise and join me for the Pledge of
Allegiance pled aliance to the flag of
the United States of America and to the
Republic for which it stands one nation
under God indivisible with liberty and
justice for
all thank you with that I will open our
first public hearing of the day on House
Bill
75 and is the prime sponsor
here House Bill
75 who are we looking for here represent
of
verville
last e
thank you Mr chair I am not the prime
sponsor of this bill but I'm introducing
it on his behalf since he is not here
today this bill is a simp uh simple
legalization bill for cannabis
legalizing it for persons uh 21 years of
age or older um and essentially just
removes the language around the
controlled Drug Act which is in our
rsa's um again just a simple
legalization Bill not getting into the
issues of recreational use or sale or
anything like that but um I will not
take questions since I did not write
this
Bill thank
you is there anyone wishing to testify
on House Bill 75
well I guess with that I will close the
public hearing on Hospital
75 and it looks like we have an hour to
kill what just happen nobody show no
keevin Kevin didn't
show
e
e e
I'm open in the public hearing on House
Bill 1 190 and invite the sponsor to
introduce the bill
thank you honorable Mr chair and uh
committee members my name is
representative Heath Howard I represent
the towns of straford and barington in
straford District 4 uh today I'm
introducing HB 190 which uh increases
therapeutic cannabis purchase and
possession limits from 2 to 4 ounces
this does not legalize cannabis for uh
recreational use this does not change
the who can purchase cannabis this does
not change anything other than the fact
that people who are already allowed to
purchase and possess cannabis for
therapeutic and medical use can now
purchase and possess more which really
does benefit them from a medical
perspective as some people do need
larger doses than others it helps reduce
uh travel in the number of trips people
need to take to the dispensaries and
overall makes it easier for the people
who are uh most in need so with that uh
because the language is pretty simple
all it does is change uh the two to the
four uh I'm open to any questions thank
you thank you um I have a question in
crafting this build did you talk to any
or work with any cannabis patients yes I
I'm actually a therapeutic cannabis
patient myself I broke my back when I
was 16 I have uh used it as an
alternative to uh things like opiates
and I I personally think that this is a
a much needed change it's something
where uh obviously uh some people uh
because we only have a limited number of
dispensaries in the state we have three
companies uh with uh only a handful of
locations so it's not exactly always
accessible for people so this way we can
help kind of uh alleviate some of that
strain on them okay so my point I guess
I was getting at is and maybe this is
great that you you're a patient
yourself have you ever utilized 2 ounces
in a month uh personally no but again
the it's it's different uh
differentiates uh we need to
differentiate between different types of
patients and the thing is is that
different patients use different amounts
and sometimes they uh actually will I
mean they'll buy in bulk and what
they'll do is make oil uh which then
they can use to cook uh different types
of food whether it may be you know a
brownie or you know even uh uh you know
something like as as basic as salad
dressing even so uh there are various
different types of uh ways that people
can utilize it and buying in bulk kind
of helps uh reduce some of these
people's needs uh to produce that oil
multiple times uh throughout the year so
okay that's interesting so the the
amount of the bulk product you're saying
um is the weight that they're allowed to
have but that's reduced down when they
um cook it or do whatever to make
something else that they're going to use
it for yes okay yeah that is corre and
I'm assuming that isett potent though
that that it it can be but it depends
again on the different strain and uh
people will then have to dose themselves
accordingly uh you know uh like I I have
a tray of brownies at home and it's
something where depending on what I want
for that evening I'll cut a differ size
piece and and uh because it's something
that I've had before I kind of
understand what the effect is going to
be on me and so I can kind of adjust
accordingly so it's something where the
patient really uh is the one kind of uh
taking it upon themselves to
self-regulate okay thank you questions
from the
committee resent
Muse I I've I have heard that uh it is
problematic for some people the the the
amount of distance uh that they have to
travel have you been contacted by people
like that and yes I mean is that is that
an issue that that comes up a lot yes it
it is especially up in the north country
uh I mean there are uh again only a
handful of dispensaries across the state
and a lot of them are in the southern
half it's something where a lot of these
patients especially in the North Country
it's a lot easier if you can cut down
the amount of trips that they're making
uh and you know if they only need to
come once every two months that's a huge
change because then that's a whole trip
that they don't need to take every month
and they can reduce that travel so
followup do you
see you know an analogy that I kind of
make in my own mind as I take a
cholesterol medication and one of the
things that my Pharmacy benefit manager
did years and years ago was uh encourag
me to buy a 90-day Supply instead of a
30-day Supply and these days I actually
pay less for the 90-day Supply than I
ever did for the 30-day Supply is there
is are we talking about something
similar yeah I mean again it's something
where whenever I purchase I always
purchase the limit because it is
something where financially speaking it
is a lot more advantageous to uh to
purchase the limit uh a lot of the times
there are some discounts that are
available when you do it that way and it
can reduce the cost
significantly and one more
followup and the cost of therapeutic
cannabis is not reimbursed by insurance
companies is that correct that is
correct thank
you with regard to the North country are
New Hampshire cannabis patients allowed
to cross the border to Vermont or Maine
in you in purchase or would that be a
violation of their contract so they can
cross state lines and purchase in other
states uh around us so uh except for
Massachusetts so Vermont uh if I'm not
mistaken uh in Maine you can go in their
medical dispensaries however you cannot
cross back into New Hampshire with that
product it is locked uh by state and you
cannot cross uh because then you would
have interstate commerce and that is
federally
legal pretty sure the whole shooting
match is federally legal but further
questions uh yes represent
s thank you for taking my question um
with respect to the North Country uh
years ago I'm going to say six or eight
years ago there was a a u a
major problem with uh
um opioids in the North country and the
the reason for that was that uh people
in the North Country couldn't Avail
themselves to physical therapy so they
had to resort to opioids for pain
relief um so I'm I'm particularly
interested when you said that there are
very few dispensaries do you know where
the closest dispensary is up north
I want to say it's in North Conway if
I'm not mistaken really so if you're in
Pittsburgh or arol or Co Brook that's a
long track yes it it is just follow up
follow pardon me but I for my ignorance
on this subject
but recently there's been some uh talk
of a synthetic cannabis called K2 or
something like
that can you explain what that
is I might not be the best one to
explain uh synthetic uh cannaboids uh
there there are other uh experts here
who who would be able to answer that
better than I okay thank
you see no further questions thank you
thank
you the chair recognizes The Honorable
Tom Manion
thank you Mr chair members of the
committee um so you guys asked a lot of
really good questions but like I think
the prime hit it like nail on the head
it's like multiple trips ends up
becoming a burden on people that are
just looking for like medical relief and
like who doesn't like to buy in bulk so
I'm a big supporter of this bill I I'm
also not an expert in this field I I'm
not a user uh there's people in my
family that are um and they may or may
not go to Massachusetts to just do it to
deal to get around the freaking hassle
um I live on the mass border so it's
convenient for me but these I hear about
these guys up in the north country and
like having to drive like an hour or
something seems absolutely egregious um
that's that's what I got I'm not sure if
I can really answer any questions but
I'm happy to take
them see no questions thank you thank
you the chair uh calls The Honorable Suk
Homa
thank you thank you for allowing me to
speak on this bill today um I'm here on
behalf of Sam New Hampshire which is a
drug prevention group a National Drug
prevention group I'm the state chairman
uh the issues that we have with hb10 is
explaining the limit of medical medical
marijuana possession from 2 to 4 ounces
is a significant increase and one of the
reasons that we keep hearing is so that
uh we can reduce travel time which is a
very Noble goal for people who may be
suffer uffing in pain uh the issue that
that I have is that we're not actually
increasing the number of days that go
along with this um if if the real goal
is to reduce the amount of trips to
medical marijuana facilities then it
this bill should also come with a
lengthening of the days so if we're
doubling the amount of marijuana then we
should double the amount of days in
state St in the state statute um we did
hear that sometimes people need
additional cannabis and things like that
but right now now um we haven't I
haven't seen any data that has um been
given to anyone on this committee that
actually gives hard data on that as
opposed to anecdotal sometimes people
like to use more cannabis um many states
to include New Hampshire like I was
saying they they list a frequency for
medical marijuana purchases overall the
majority of medical marijuana states set
their limit at 2.5 ounces or less that's
the majority uh there are a sizable uh
handful of legalized States who do it
kind of an interesting way is they
actually do it based off of a one month
supply or a 30 or a 60-day supply but
they do that with the doctor actually
prescribing the amount so they don't
actually put a limit on how much
cannabis people say they say that the
their doctor has to prescribe an amount
and then they're allowed to have a one
month or whatever Supply so that's kind
of an interesting way to think about
that if that's truly an issue that might
be a novel way to approach that um to
determine the the depth of the medical
marijuana user accessibility in New
Hampshire I really believe that
therapeutic cannabis oversight or the
Cannabis program should document the
number of users who are significantly
affected and uh that's all I have to say
on this bill I did want to say on
another note I won't be able to be here
all day but there are a number of
medical marijuana bills that are being
heard yesterday that were heard
yesterday in the Health and Human
Services committee one of the things
that uh is relative for you all is today
is I would really request that you look
at the totality of all these bills
because yesterday I there was a bill
that wanted to re um that wanted to
um allow homegrown for medical marijuana
and what you'll hear later today is this
in this homegrown bill it had no
enforcement no inspection it was totally
on the honor System it um also kind of
hamstrung law enforcement in their
ability if they say if they suspect
somebody who is growing something
illegal they have a lot of difficulty
actually trying to get the to find out
if that person's under the program or
not um you'll be hearing later today HB
380 which was removes the felony for
selling mirical marijuana to
non-designated individuals I just want
to let you know that yesterday in
testimony one of the things that I heard
that why homegrown was a good idea was
because we already have these
Protections in place we already have
this this there's no problem you know
there's enough deterrence but you're
listening to a bill today that actually
is removing that one protection so I'm
just giving you I'm just encouraging you
if you could when you're considering
your bills to look at the totality of it
because uh Sam New Hampshire is kind of
concerned at the amount of play on the
uh to undermine some of the safeguarding
law enforcement protections that are in
right now for the medical marijuana
program does anyone have any questions
I'm happy to answer them thank you do
you or does your organization have any
um data with regard to the amounts of
marijuana that um medical pay Pati use
in other words in the other states what
are they what what are they using the
only data that I have and I'll I'll send
you all the electronic testimony that I
have later um the only data that I have
is data on what other states do for
their medical marijuana program what's
the highest um gosh the highest is8
ounces and I think that's like
California Oregon one of those too um
that was the highest but for the most
part and that's in a month that's just
in general they I don't I from what I
could tell they didn't have a a time
limit on it it was just sort of a
possession um so in most of them I
counted up the number of states who in
the ounces I did a little chart of like
okay who has what ounces and things like
that and like I said the majority about
I would say 60% were 2.5 ounces or less
um yesterday we heard in the Health and
Human Services Community uh committee
somebody testified that that hom grow is
legal in other states and it's not it's
not legal in all other states um there's
actually kind of caps on that as well so
um that if you happen to hear that today
that's not a actual fact you have data
that we could I'd be happy to share with
committee sir yes sir thank you any
questions see oh yeah representative
share yes sir just to F just to follow
up on what uh the chair said um I'd love
to see the little chart you did I think
that'd be very helpful for the committee
great I will I'll pass that along thank
you thank
you thank you heie the chair recognizes
Heather Marie
Brown sorry sorry about that uh
representative kerk unfortunately
couldn't be here to join us today so he
did have testimony that he wanted me to
turn in for
him sorry so my name is Heather Marie
Brown and I actually am the patient
representative for the therapeutic
cannabis medical oversight board I also
serve as the alternate chair the reason
I'm here today instead of Jerry is
because of the fact that he felt and we
all felt that I could give a better
perspective on this since it is myself
and the patient population within the
state that this
impacts um we are in unanimous support
of this bill we were in support of it
before when it had a different number
and previously came before you and we
are still in unanimous support of this
bill uh we have come to realize over the
last few years that cost and
affordability and accessibility are
major hurdles for some of our patients
also what we've come to realize and also
myself from personal experience is that
I has a patient consumed cannabis in
multiple ways there are times throughout
the day where it is appropriate for me
to sit down and inhale my cannabis
through smoking and there are other
times throughout the day where it is
inappropriate of me to do so so I um
utilize Edibles or ures or things of
that nature um the thing that comes with
that is for myself I cannot afford to go
to the dispensary and to purchase
Edibles and to purchase tinctures and to
purchase the items that I need to carry
me throughout the month but if I was
able to purchase 4 ounces of cannabis at
one time I could go home and I can make
my butter and I can make my oil and I
can make my tinkerers and then I am all
set for a month of that along with what
I need for flower um to take if I follow
the law by the letter of it I have to
pick up 2 ounces I have to wait 10 days
to pick up two more ounces there's 20
days of the month now technically I'm in
violation of the law because I have 4
ounces sitting at home and then I take
that 4 ounces I make my butter I make my
tinure and I have 30 days worth of what
I need to help me get through um I don't
think that that's appropriate I don't
think that it's right I don't think that
at any point in time should I have to
feel like I'm skirting around the law or
violating the law or that I'm a criminal
I fought very long and hard to take
control of my Healthcare and I am
extremely proud of where I am today um
you know you you watch me walk over here
I'm 47 years old I'm a mother of three
children if I didn't have my therapeutic
cannabis I would already be in a
wheelchair um I think that the change in
the law is extremely long overdue and I
think that it has many many benefits to
our patients because again yes
Transportation uh can be an issue uh
distance can be an issue cost and
affordability can be an issue but at the
end of the day it's really on how each
individual patient chooses to treat
their ailments for some it's inhalation
2 ounces of flour every 10 days may be
appropriate for others it involves
consumption through other means and it's
not appropriate and we need the larger
amounts um you know I know this is some
math but when I take 4 ounces of
cannabis and I go to make oil with it
there technically is only a 30% return
on it so if you're trying to do that
with 1 o or 2 O you're getting
absolutely nothing back which will mean
that you have no sustainable amount to
get you any farther than you know the 10
days or the 15 days with the 4 o you
have a much greater return and I'm able
to treat my illness my ailments
appropriately and for a longer duration
of time therefore saving myself money
saving myself time and travel and saving
you know like I said I have three
children so who's going to babysit them
while I make a trip off to the
dispensary that doesn't come for free so
um I think this bill
is something that you should definitely
pass and definitely support and I I
think that it will decrease a lot of the
barriers that some of our patients face
these days and I do know that we have a
wonderful the medical oversight board
has a wonderful relationship with the
dispensaries and um you know we do do
annual reports and so forth and although
I don't have those numbers on me you are
more than welcome to get on our website
and we do have have annual reports that
give you some of the data that you were
asking questions about earlier I also
know that if you were to reach out to
the dispensaries that the dispensaries
would be more than willing to cooperate
and and give you answers to some of
those questions as well because really
they're the ones that work with the
patients and see how much is actually
being utilized and distributed and you
know Edibles versus flowers and things
like that so I do hope that you will
vote and support this bill and pass it
on to to the next level so because I
still should not feel like I'm am doing
something wrong when all I'm trying to
do is maintain my health and my ability
to be a productive member of society and
a contributing member here in New
Hampshire so thank you very much if you
have any
questions thank you um about how how
long will that 4 ounces last you u based
on your personal therapy that you need
uh for myself if I can obtain 4 ounces
at one time I'm able to produce enough
butter and enough oil and enough
tincture that I will that I'm able to
get through the month with that I do
still need the accessibility to the
flower as well because as I said there
are certain times of the day or certain
conditions where it's more appropriate
for me to use the flour versus the
Edibles or the
tinctures do you find a a difference in
the level of therapy you receive from
the flower versus for example The Vape
cartridges or do you not use those at
all I myself do not use the Vape
cartridges um I've always just kind of
been a natural kind of gal so um you
know I U utilize primarily my flow um I
have to where all of our T our cannabis
is tested there are actually certain
profiles that I look for in the Cannabis
that I select and that includes when I'm
using the Cannabis to create Edibles and
so
forth so further
questions yes representative um
new thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question um I was just
wondering I think it would be um
enlightening especially as a therapeutic
cannabis patient to understand a little
bit about um what kind of what is uh the
difference in
um can you speak to when it is more
appropriate um to consume an edible in
that form
medically um so for certain people
myself included um I suffer from chronic
pain I suffer from PTSD and a few other
ailments but those are the two that I
received my card for um there are
instances where um we'll say a panic
attack may start sitting in my anxiety
may start increasing um at that time I
would utilize a flower to smoke and
inhale because it is a much faster
acting way to get it into my system and
it has almost instant effect and helps
to bring me back down so I can function
um there are times most of the time I
utilize um Edibles because they take a
little bit longer to affect uh to take
effect but they also last a little bit
longer too as well um so I like to view
them almost like when you when you're an
asmatic and you have a rescue inhaler
and then you have your regular
medication that you take each day you
know so that's that's kind of how I
utilize cannabis so when I like say for
today I I I can't I can't utilize
inhalation methods here no matter how
nervous or anxious I am yeah we would
prefer that you
didn't so you know it would be
completely inappropriate of me to walk
outside the state house and light up a
blunt and say hallelujah and come back
in but before I left my home I did make
sure that I was able to um have a little
bit of butter on my toast to make sure
that my pain would be under control and
to make sure that any of the little
butterflies I may or may not have
throughout the day um are kept at Bay
and as you can see even for somebody
that's on cannabis and that just
consumed a few hours ago I'm not wacky
I'm not doing anything disrespectful I'm
normal I'm functioning I'm able to walk
over here and sit down and you know
share my experiences with you and that's
not different from any other patient
that we have on the program so all all
we want to do is be able to take our
health into our own control and and be
able to do what we need to do so that we
can be functioning members of society so
that we can interact with everyone and
be the best that we possibly can be and
change our future
outcomes thank you appreciate that um
one one last question for me um how
often would it be that you would
actually be driving around with that
much product with you 4 ounces I mean
that wouldn't be the case would it it
for me specifically once a month I I
would utilize that for once a month I
would go I would pick up my 4 ounces I
would go home I would make whatever I
needed to make in 10 days I would go
back to make sure I had flour that I
needed for the rest of the month and I
would be okay it would cut my dispensary
trips down over half I would save money
I would not have to make the decision do
I want to cross the border today because
yes that may be illegal but
unfortunately sometimes our patients are
actually driven to that point where they
are crossing the border they are
purchasing cannabis in other states and
they're risking prosecution and jail
time coming back over the border just so
they can be able to treat themselves
that shouldn't that shouldn't be a
problem and it shouldn't be you know
something that we encourage and
unfortunately unless we increase The
Possession limits it's almost like the
state is encouraging that type of
behavior and I don't think that's what
the state intended to
do thank you very much oh yeah M uh
represent
Mel thank you for taking taking my
question and and I apologize for my
ignorance on this subject and it might
be too personal but in your case MH
where you purchase uh 4 oz plus per
month how much does that cost you for
your
medication
oh through the New Hampshire
dispensaries if I have to do it 2 ounces
at a time I am potentially looking at
$1,000 or even more per month
yes I I am not going to say yes or no
but I am going to say that I am one of
those patients that maybe once or twice
has been tempted to go through other
means and cross state borders just to
make sure
that I can maintain my level of Health
needed to be a functioning member
to be there for my
children followup Mr
chairman cannabis is available outside
the dispensaries on the streets MH how
much would it cost you if you were able
to purchase it that way do you have any
idea I unfortunately do and it is part
of my language a hell of a lot cheaper
unfortunately through the black market
but as a patient I know that the black
market is unregulated I know that there
is a possibility that I am not getting
something that is clean or that is safe
or that I should be even putting in my
body so that is not a solution
thankfully that I have chosen to take I
I have thought about it once or twice
but if I'm trying to control my health
care and I'm trying to provide the best
health that I can for myself then I need
to be very careful of where I do
purchase my cannabis so I choose to
purchase it from dispensaries and
reputable sources that I know my
medication is being tested I know that
what I'm receiving is clean and I know
that I'm not going to get sick from it
one more
followup you said with respect to on the
street you said it's a heck of a lot
cheaper mhm so versus
$1,000 just in an average what would
that type of that level of of dosage
cost you on the
street half
or well let's just say that there are
opportunities available in this state
and in other states for that kind of
transaction to to happen and you are
literally looking at Pennies on the
dollar so what an ounce would cost here
in New
Hampshire can in some instances acquire
a half a pound in another area in
another state in another market so 1/8
would
be so I'm talking about a half a pound
versus the cost of an ounce
an oun is 28
gram we'll just stick with a heck of a
lot cheaper yes thank you very much for
your testimony
Y for the uninformed like
myself it seems like there are very few
um
dispensaries and I see other um
retail places that advertise CBD what's
what is that all
about so CBD can be derived in many
different Fashions the CBD that you see
advertised that are that's available at
the gas station or the health food store
or anything like that that is derived
from the hemp plant which the federal
Farm Bill protects which New Hampshire
says is okay to do um you know so those
facilities are able to get hemp derived
CBD and sell them in their locations and
give them to people um I am definitely
not saying that there is anything wrong
with that because there's not sometimes
that's what a person needs but most
patients rely on what we call the onage
effect and that is where CBD THC and
every other cannaboid that's in the
plant
works together so it's not always
necessarily best for us to utilize only
one can cannaboid but in some cases it
is so the difference between hemp
derived and between medicinal CBD that
has actually come from a plant that
contains THC is basically the THC amount
within the plant I I think it's
3% point it's 3% for um in order for the
plant to be considered
hemp um in the medicinal world the
dispensaries when they grow a CBD strain
it usually does not meet the hemp
standard and because it has a little
higher concentration of the THC and the
other cannaboids but that is absolutely
wonderful and again that's where the
Entourage effect comes in and it's
available for more people to be able to
utilize
thank you it's it's basically um like uh
comparing Heen refer to Old
duels it's one's one's uh got no alcohol
well I I I know about the relationship
there so that's an anal that analogy is
good but then so how would that work
with the comparison between CBD and hemp
product
like there's a big difference between
Recreation marijuana and and CBD yeah
CBD has there is some some relationship
between CBD and hemp yeah so would that
be as great for both of them or no the
the the one that you would get at like a
convenience store it's my understanding
it um it's it's like one ingredient of
the hemp plant the part that doesn't
have the uh hallucinogenic effect or the
painkilling effect
it's it's more of um it's considered
more of like a a supplement type thing
but in all of the products you get it
from that combination yes right it's but
the combination has very small
quantities of some of it and it has
larger quantity of the CB okay great
thank
you um no further questions thank
you I if it's all right I just would
like to say thank you so much and I do
appreciate the questions
um I think that this is an opportunity
for all of us to be able to learn
something new and so I thank you for
your open mindness thank
you um to chair um calls The Honorable
um Joe
Hannah good morning uh thank you for
listening to us today uh my name is Joe
Hannon um I'm a former State Rep I was
also the public member on the 2018
commission to study legalization and
taxation of marijuana they called it at
the time uh and I'm also on The Advisory
board for the New Hampshire cannabis
Association I'm in favor of this bill um
I'm not going to go into too many of the
reasons we heard because we've heard
about the the travel times and you know
I think most of us have a Costco card or
a BJ's Club card so we understand buying
in bulk saves money but I don't think uh
some of us realize um some may I I
realized this in the last few years how
difficult it is for some people just to
leave the house sometimes because of
their medical conditions um you know I
had a cousin who was was agoraphobic you
know with fear of public places going my
dad thought I was angor phobic I'm like
it's not sweaters it's she didn't want
to go outside but um I I had severe back
pain and I wasn't able to leave um I was
able to but it was extremely difficult
for me I actually went out and bought
five pairs of sandals because I couldn't
tie my shoes for a while um driving was
extremely difficult I just had to drop
my son back off of college and it was a
4-Hour Drive each way and I was I'm much
better now but it was a very difficult
thing for a seemingly healthy young
person to do
um you know someone who has a chronic
pain condition uh or other chronic
illnesses like cancer or you know and
any other person who may be in Hospice
Care leaving the house is not an option
uh and if it is it's it's going to be
very planned very focused and it's it's
much a bigger bigger deal than people
think
um also we heard from you know people
like Heather um they need to make their
tinctures or edibles we don't want
people to smoke more necessarily from a
harm reduction state standpoint it's you
know the preferred way of most it's easy
people get it it's they know what
they're getting right away but sometimes
it's better to make edibles for for all
kinds of reasons um and also we don't
want people on the roads as much you
know we want people to dve you know to
be we don't want people using substances
and being on the roads and most people
are trying not to do that but I
guarantee there's going to be a
percentage of people who drive to the
liquor store a little too buzzed or
drive to the cannabis store a little too
Under the Influence it happens we want
to minimize that effect by not having
them just drive an hour to these stores
or driving out of state they're not
going to stop using it if it's really
necessary and they're able to get out of
the house they're going to go to some
other store um if if it's that cheap on
the streets we don't want to push people
towards the street so if we want to
combat the black market keep people safe
on the roads protect our environment not
waste money not waste gas not waste our
time not suffer and not prohibit people
who have a medical problem this is not
recreational like we've heard a million
times if you want recreational you can
go to the state liquor store and fill up
a tractor trailer full of whiskey that's
fine but a medical patient has to have a
certain amount and not more because
that's bad for whatever I don't know
what what they're really um it doesn't
make sense this is something that we've
admitted as a medication people need it
it changes lives it's it drastically
transforms many people's lives and if
someone needs that much of it it's
absolutely necessary for them to get it
um I've also last point I'll make um not
the last one but the second last the
I've I've done a lot of time in other
disaster zones and I've seen what
happens when natural disaster occur I'm
not a crazy I don't have a bunker in my
backyard I don't have two years worth of
Beats and a a barrel but I have I
prepare myself for when the snow goes
when the power goes out for snow
emergencies or disasters I've lived in
Florida I've survived many hurricanes I
was in Katrina for five weeks doing
working with police officers and I
noticed not to notice but it was blaring
one of the biggest problems I didn't
hear about in a disaster and I'm sure
it's happening in LA right now all these
officers and firefighters they might not
be able to have access to their
medications I'm not even I'm not talking
about cannabis but just in general they
might not have access to the medications
so if someone's up north that's you know
I get snowed in on the Sea Coast you
don't think they get snowed in more up
north and don't want to go on the roads
I don't like driving at night I'm pretty
young my eyes aren't that bad yet but
you know you don't want people to go out
the sun goes down at 3:30 it's Pitch
Black it's cold and they're in pain you
want to make people go out more often I
get annoyed because I have to drive you
know four miles to get Chinese food
where I live uh you don't want people to
have to be in that situation and as far
as last thing we we heard a an illusion
they mentioned the other committees and
bills and I don't like to do this I know
it's not allowed but since it happened I
figured it'll be okay yeah thanks um
appreciate it uh you know about no
regulation for hom grow uh and you're
going to hear this and it's relative to
this because if people were able to grow
it at home they wouldn't need as much at
the store and most people aren't going
to do it it's very difficult I wouldn't
plan on it I can barely keep a cactus
alive but you can grow two you can Brew
200 gallons of beer wine if you have two
adults in the house over 21 that's about
a sixpack a day and no regulation no
oversight when we were on the commission
and we asked the Liquor Commission if
they do anything about it they're they
kind of looked at us like well no it's
just Homebrew no one cares it's not a
problem there's no big operations going
on but if there were people would be
getting better you know Med these plants
are going to be coming from stores or
known Growers so there's going to be a
known strain or quantity of uh cannabis
if it's going to be diverted and we'll
get to that later on the the penalty
bills for people in the program but um
you know they're getting something
that's not corrupted with other drugs or
adulterated so I don't recommend it I
don't think it should be done but if
it's if it's going to happen I'd rather
someone get it from from their
grandfather or grandmother um and not
get it from the street so there's a lot
of reasons why people have limited drug
quantities in the past and some of them
are for safety the number one now public
safety aside they're mostly for uh
personal safety like we don't want to
give someone not that they can easily
die from an overdose but most
medications that are prescribed a 30-day
Supply can kill most people I can list
probably 100 drugs off the top of my
head that'll probably kill you if you
take a 30-day Supply and they give it
out like like nothing um so is it to
limit other people getting it I I don't
know how effective it really is but it's
definitely cheaper I would definitely
buy in bulk if I could do it I know
before Co who bought toilet paper in
huge bulk you know so it's hypocritical
for me hypocritical for me not to say
that people should be allowed to prepare
themselves and not be in a position
where they're meant to suffer because of
an unjust
law be happy to take any questions thank
you except K2 I just thought that was a
mountain
um 2 ounces yeah so for me that sounds
like a real lot is is it um could you
give us a a I mean I know it's kind of
this etheral thing like how much for
each patient um you know I'm going back
to the high school days with the bag I
mean how two ounces how much is that
that sounds like a lot of I mean I I
haven't seen it I haven't wor I haven't
sat down with a 2 ooun bag since college
but uh a lot right it it was quite a bit
um and I was I actually asked several
people because I don't smoke um
and the the question is you know is it a
lot it it varies I prescribed opiates to
people in my practice uh very sparingly
since I was someone in long-term
recovery I was very hesitant to do so so
I was one of those people who was very
cautious about and and this is back when
everyone was just handing them out um
and even now I probably do less than I
did
as far as prescribing but I see people
that would come in on a daily basis with
enough opiates in their system that
could kill three people yeah and they
take them like it's nothing and they're
functioning I have a friend who's in end
of lifeare right now and she's taking
enough opiates and she's been driving
for 20 years like this yeah F she's
absolutely you know fine appearing
tolerance builds tolerance builds up I'm
not saying that you know I don't want to
get into the debate about what we should
be allowed to drive with under opiates
and things but it's happening um whether
we know it or not but I think it's
important to say that uh you know is 2 O
A lot you know someone who's taking
enough opiates to kill a large farm
animal that's nothing but the opius have
a lethal dose all drugs have a and real
quick medical background uh you might
hear you won't hear this a lot but ld50
is a lethal dose 50 that means what
dosage a certain drug has to be to kill
about half the people so half the people
will live maybe not doing well but half
the people will probably die at that
will die at that dose every drug that's
described has that dose I don't know
offand what the lethal dose for cannabis
is in studies cuz there haven't been any
it's it's actually you can't overdose on
it you can get sick you can get you know
all kinds of weird feelings but no one's
going to die from it unless it actually
falls now if we I let them have enough
that it could fall in their head like a
bail of it landing on someone's head
from a farm Barn yes that is a lethal
dose of cannabis so if you want to know
how much cannabis will kill you it's
probably the size of a bail of hay um
from a height cuz I could probably hold
that on my head so it's got to be from a
height but you know is that too much I
would think it would be an awful lot but
for someone with chronic pain or a
chronic opiate problem might not be that
much at all I know people that do a
th000 milligrams of tinctures or edibles
a month and that's a lot but um to to
get that much flour to make a tinure
ebles on your own you'd need more uh and
I'd rather see people doing that than
getting opiates or other more far more
dangerous prescription drugs or
non-prescription drugs from the street
whatever I know K2 or whatever it is um
and and cost is an issue so
um thank you for the question and sorry
for the long answer no thank you that
the tolerance thing was actually a good
point good um further questions yes
represent
Newman back to the questions I was
talking about
before in the analogy between regular
beer and
odules so you have some t
um THC in the medical
marijuana and you have some in the plant
more
obviously and if you were drinking beer
you could get a buzz on but to get the
same Buzz with the nonalcoholic beer you
probably have to drink a case is there
the same kind of analogy like that
between uh I I am an expert on the
subject I I stopped drinking many years
ago but I was a pretty bad Drinker uh if
it's you know people that drink
non-alcoholic beers I see people there
are some people in recovery that are
just don't want to go near it and I know
some that do drink it and those that do
Don't Think Twice especially when it's
zero there are alul when originally came
out I think it was 0.5% so you'd have to
drink what 12 to get the equivalent of
one beer on average um one beer does not
get too many people I know even mildly
buzzed but to get two beers you have to
drink a case yeah or is that right no 12
12 pack um they could but it's just a
matter of how big your stomach is I mean
you have to drink like a if you can you
can the average stomach can expand to
about a gallon um more with training
that's another discussion but um um I
can eat a lot of chicken nuggets but
anyway um so yeah I don't think that
you're going to get that problem now
people can buy uh your question I think
was about earlier about CBD yeah now
it's the non psychoactive one of the
many non- psychoactive parts of the
cannabis plant um and just the
percentage doesn't mean that you know
hemp plants and true cannabis plants
don't necessarily um they don't they
have they have both they have both but
the percentages are much lower so they
they the cannabis plants that are being
made you know grown now much higher
percentages of THC they still have CBD
in them but that's not um as
as I wouldn't say readily available it's
it's not the prime reason why some
people are using it now you heard uh
someone talk about the Entourage effect
when you take CBD with different kinds
of now there's multiple kinds of CBD and
I'd love to talk to you about that but
I'm sure we could that in the hallway
because that'll take a lot longer but
when you take um THC the psychoactive
chemical in in cannabis with uh TBD and
other other CBD CBN um you know and some
others you you can Al can have different
effects and sometimes they're better um
and a lot of people find um you know CBD
is good for different conditions but to
a certain point so the doses is
important for a lot of
um well for any drug the dose and also
the poison is in the dose like I said if
you take too much it's poison it's like
water if you have too much will kill you
so we should limit W you know swiming
pools are deadly but we can have as much
as we want in the swimming pool you know
but it can kill people it's one of the
number one killers of young children
under the age of five um so CBD can have
hemp derived products can have THC in it
but it's a very small amount you won't
necessarily get high from it or have any
uh effects but if you take enough of
them you could you know I've seen uh
people get a an edible container with
maybe 30 um CBD chewies or gummies or
whatever in it and I think a standard
you know dose of them is 30 milligrams
of CBD or maybe more some some are 60
but 30 to throw that number out there
there might be 30 of CBD in it and to
have 0.3% there might be one of th one
milligram of
THC now that does have THC and it would
be illegal if it came from a cannabis
plant but if it came from a plant where
the whole thing only has 3% we're
talking about flowers so Edibles they
can change it but it's not illegal and
you're probably not you'd have to take
the whole you can get 30 milligrams
which is quite a large U amount of THC
for a a a new individual who hasn't done
it before uh but you have to take 30 of
them and it becomes cross it can be
cross prohibitive uh you know it's they
they charge the same amount of for a
gummy with CBD and and 1 milligram of
THC that's hemp derived as they might do
for for an edible with a lot more THC so
to get the same effect You' have to buy
a you know the equivalent of a case of
old DS or more to get a little bit out
of it and it's not worth it you're going
to feel other effects you know I'd love
to eat a bag of candy but I'm going to
get you know other problems from that
thank you
sure yes um again I apologize for my
ignorance here but uh one of the the
things that makes
fentol so
so um such a big deal is compared to
heroin it's much less
expensive uh it's well fentanyl is not
only usually cheaper it's easier to
smuggle you know instead of having to
bring this much in you can just bring in
this much um it's more lethal um and
it's harder to tirate something like
that you can't um when you take a
medicine if you're taking cannabis with
tinctures you have an eye dropper you
can say okay I need three drops or half
of a milliliter or whatever you're
taking you cut a gummy in half if you
only need a certain amount but if you're
doing Fentanyl and they shoot it up and
I worked with syringe programs for a
long time I helped get some of a lot of
those started if you have uh a syringe
and you pull it up with fentanyl in it
um you know there might be this much in
the syringe and you might push that much
into your vein not me but you know put
that much in most of the fenel might be
in that last half you know so if you do
if you if you chop something up it might
be it's not all
and if you get pure heroin you know what
you're getting like back many years ago
I worked in a in a hospital in a very
high heroin um area um prevalent area
they uh people would go out and say oh
someone died of an overdose we want that
because it was the Pure Heroin it wasn't
cut up because people would take it and
not know what they were taking you know
they people overdose when they don't
know how much they're taking often
follow up yeah sorry chairman um sorry
if I'm ignorant the reason I ask is that
obviously cost is an issue and it's my
understanding and again I'm rather
Elementary here but K2 is a synthetic
form of cannabis yes
um if they're able to produce K2 much
cheaper than the natural form of
cannabis would that take some of the
bite out out of the cost of
therapy uh I don't know a lot about the
pharmacology of K2 so I I don't really
to feel competent to speak on it I don't
know why someone would get
um I I don't know why someone would do
that I mean I don't understand other
than cost um and you know we've heard
people testify for and especially we're
talking about Med medical right here
people in the medical program are
they're paying a premium and still going
to the dispensaries and not that they're
way higher prices they're they're you
know competitive to a degree but they're
it is cheaper when you can buy uh other
products now since the the people in the
medical program are not looking for K2
they will they will probably not use
that unless it's just to try it out for
whatever reason it's so much easier just
to go somewhere else if that's the case
uh we're surrounded by states it is not
a problem when at the in the commission
when we heard testimony all the
prevention groups they brought all the
kids in talking about how it's so
prevalent it's everywhere and I don't
disagree it's it's very prevalent uh for
for young kids to get it was harder for
them to get alcohol um especially I have
a freshman in college son and it's much
easier for them to get you know cannabis
than alcohol sometimes um and well not
when it got to college it's little
easier to get alcohol but in high school
um so I I don't think that that that's
who's going to buy stuff like that or
more likely to get at the gas station is
someone who can't go in a dispensary
with because they're 21 so people that
are using that are probably under 21 or
um you know just don't have any money at
all and we're talking very very uh you
know low on funds to to try that over
something that's the real
thing it's a good question but I don't
think it's relevant to
Medical thank you for your
testimony thank you this last one Matt
Simon the chair
calls thank you Mr chairman for the
record my name is Matt Simon I work for
granite Leaf cannabis we are a nonprofit
therapeutic cannabis alternative
treatment center uh we have a production
facility located in Peterboro New
Hampshire we operate two dispensaries
one in marac one in Chai Chester and we
support this bill for the reasons you've
already heard and I will elaborate a
little bit on a couple things the main
reason is what you've already heard from
Heather Marie Brown uh most of the
patients that visit our dispensary do
not by the limit but we do realize the
therapeutic canvas is very individual uh
different patients have very different
needs and as you heard a small subset of
our patient population needs a lot more
than the average person so it is to
accommodate those individuals
particularly if they live in outlying
areas uh we have seven dispensaries in
the state there's one in Conway there's
one in Plymouth so the North Country in
particular is quite some distance um so
it would help that patient population
most dramatically it would also help all
of our patients because one of the
confusing aspects of our program is that
we have to track patients allotment when
the bill originally passed in
2013 it was assumed that cannabis flour
would be the product now it's a wide
range of things from you know brownies
tinctures edibles we make capsules we
make
suppositories Vape cartridges really a
lot of things and 2 O is a flower amount
so for every product we make there is a
corresponding amount that that
translates to in flour and so we have to
do math and patients are often extremely
confused about how much of their
allotment they have left how much they
can continue to purchase usually they're
way below the 2 oz but it's it's hard
for them to understand that and our
staff has to spend a lot of time
explaining to them frankly I wouldn't be
able to explain it very well cuz I don't
understand it very well so it would ease
a lot of confusion around What patients
can buy and can't buy at any given
time um we heard the 10day limit as an
issue so I support the bill as it's
currently written uh if that's the
sticking point
I think there might be a potential
compromise uh if the bill was amended to
4 ounces every 15 or 20 days something
like that uh it would help the the the
patients who live in say Pittsburgh if
they could they're not trying to come
every 10 days uh so that might be a
potential compromise I haven't discussed
that with the prime sponsor or with any
stakeholders but it it would be better
than not passing this bill in my opinion
um on to a few other topics that have
been raised if if I may uh so the price
of cannabis uh it is more expensive in
New Hampshire for a number of reasons we
discussed some of those reasons in
committee yesterday there are a few
bills that would help us bring those
prices down I will say we have brought
prices down considerably uh our
leadership team's been in place for
three and a half years at Granite Leaf
uh when we took charge all igh ounces of
cannabis in New Hampshire were $55 e
which was
exorbitant uh and just earlier this week
we reduced flower prices for the third
time uh they're now down somewhere
between 30 and 40% overall from when
where we started uh
currently uh most of our flour is $199
for an ounce so you it' be 5 ounces
under a th000 and some of our flowers in
a little higher tier so it's 239 an
ounce those prices are all on our
website and if you're curious about the
prices I just encourage you to look at
the atc's websites everything we have is
listed and also look at neighboring
states and see what uh cannabis is
selling for in both the adult use and
and medical markets I I do this research
all the time because it's part of my job
uh but basically we're working very hard
to lower prices and every time we're
able to lower prices a little bit due to
Market factors in neighboring states
they've lowered them even more so the
expectations continually change and
we're always trying to play catchup and
never quite succeeding but we are
trying synthetic cannaboids is a huge
issue I've been working on for a long
time uh we want patients to have access
to Natural
cannabis cannabis is the scientific name
for the plant it doesn't know the plant
doesn't know whether it's hemp or quote
unquote marijuana hemp is a legal
definition uh that arbitrarily says any
cannabis plant that is less than 3% THC
by dry weight is hemp and any other
cannabis plant that has more THC than
that is not hemp so when the farm bill
passed in
2018 this whole game changed prior to
that we were hearing a lot about spice
and K2 which are not cannabis at all
spice and K2 are fake cannabis they are
different types of plant material that
are sprayed with synthetic chemicals
that are designed to resemble canabo
they aren't even actually canabo so that
stuff was awful and we worked hard to
get it out of the convenience stores
there was a study commission 10 years
ago that I worked with and ultimately
prohibited those products then hemp
became federally legal and we were in
round two of this now because since the
federal government has not regulated
hemp production has not regulated CBD
markets has not stepped in to regulate
any of this it's all fallen on the
states to regulate some states aren't
regulating at all so we have a massive
hemp derived Market in cannabinoids like
CBD uh I think any analogy to alcohol
fails because alcoholic beverages
there's one molecule that's active it's
ethanol we're all pretty familiar with
that one cannabis has over a 100
potentially cannabinoids in it THC is
the one that is intoxicating or
potentially intoxicating there are over
a 100 non- intoxic canabo that are
increasingly the focus of
research and they can all be produced
from hemp and they are being produced
from hemp and there's a massive
unregulated market for these products
there's also hemp companies that are
realizing they can make more money by
synthesizing THC products from hemp and
that's where we run into trouble and New
Hampshire has prohibited that last
two sessions ago uh passed a law to
prohibit hemp dve synthetic th products
and last year eliminated the sunset on
that bill so they're illegal to sell in
New Hampshire uh but they are still very
much available and that's a whole
another
messy Federal issue that may or may not
be addressed in this year's farm bill
and I'll certainly be tracking that uh
but back to this bill we're trying to
help patients here we serve uh they're a
little over 15 ,000 patients currently
registered for the therapeutic cannabis
program we're trying to make life as
okay as possible for them and this bill
would do that
so ask you to pass it happy to answer
any
questions thank you um as as you you
said you represent one of the eight um
um stores I have a question how have you
ever been visited by or anyone from the
federal government like the um for
example the ATF like that do you keep on
hand records that were they to show up
that would show patient names that had
been there that are purchasing things
there if federal agents showed up at our
facility yeah keeping in mind I mean it
is illegal federally so the the ATF
could theoretically show up do you
maintain records there that they could
use to trace back the patients in our
state we do maintain those records I
don't think we would be very interested
in sharing in them with federal agents
so it's interesting uh the therapeutic
cannabis law includes a specific
prohibition uh the Department of Health
and Human Services cannot share patient
information with the ATF if they showed
up at DHHS they're not allowed to do it
right uh what nobody's ever asked what I
think we would want a court order
obviously we're not going to just hand
over I'm concerned Pati or we have a lot
of veterans that that absolutely that
take advantage of this product to help
them with their PTSD and many of them I
don't think realize that were the ATF to
show up with the subpoena um you would
not have much of a choice but to turn
over those records I mean you may go
into court but I I I would I would say
it would probably be a losing
proposition so I'm interested in somehow
shielding that information I appreciate
the question and I'm interested in
shielding patients from any potential
negative legal consequences uh our law
is tighter than most on this some states
allow that kind of sharing with with
federal agents we've explicitly
prohibited and that was the main reason
for that but yeah we would fight in
court to prevent anything like that from
happening and I'm heartened by the fact
that it has not happened at all anywhere
that this is uh prosecutions for you
know for example the firearm issue have
been very very few and far between and
very selective and there have actually
been a number of court rulings that call
the entire constitutionality of that
prohibition into question so I'm
somewhat hopeful that that will change
not because I think Congress is
particularly functional but because I
think the Court decisions are going in
the direction that some court is going
to throw that out uh and say that as
long as you're not impaired at the time
there's no reason why somebody who
happens to consume or possess cannabis
should be prohibited from owning a
firearm well as often is the case with
the our federal friends it would come
down to what did you put on a form the
piece of paper when they go to purchase
firearm
right it's got nothing to do with
whether they're actually using it or not
it's what they put on that form I would
agree yeah there's a big gap between how
the ATF interprets federal law and
applies it to that form and what a
number of Courts across the country have
said on this issue when it's actually
come up so thank you well I may reach
out to you after to discuss certainly
thank you any further questions yes
representative new yeah just in the very
beginning of your testimony you said I I
don't know whether it was not for-profit
or a nonprofit would uh the New
Hampshire alternative treatment centers
are required to be organized as
nonprofits at the state level we are not
recognized as nonprofits by the federal
government so that puts us in an odd
state of limbo there's another bill and
another committee on that thank you
representative
share thank you Mr chair um just for for
your information for the chair's
information to to show up with the the
ATF would have to show up to get the
names of people they would have to show
up with a search warrant to get the
search warrant they would need to have
probable cause to believe there was
evidence of a crime in in the names they
were seeking so it couldn't be a a
general hey let's get these names and
see what we can come up with it would
have to be targeted at a specific person
or persons for whom they they have
probable cause to believe is committing
a crime just I I would posit that a
store that has a big sign out front that
says we sell marijuana is probably C it
there's a federal crime happening
because it's illegal said it would be um
a I mean it would stretch and it would
go to court but well it yeah we sell
marijuana that give probable cause to uh
search the place but not for the names
it would just to information about the
owners and it would be messy yeah it
would be if I may we do have limited
protection from federal enforcement it's
about the most limited form you can have
in the form of a budget amendment that's
been
approved as part of the last several
Federal budgets it simply prohibits
federal agencies from spending money to
undermine State cannabis laws okay so I
would have to fight them in court over
that too there'd be a lot of fights
going on but I don't anti I think you're
right that it would it would be targeted
towards one individual in the unlikely
event that the feds showed up at our
dispensary they would not be trying to
access our entire records I think that
ship is sailed and the federal
government has moved on to other
priorities
rightly so thank
you with that oh we're all set thank
thank you um with that is there anyone
else who hasn't testified in this bill
that wishes to
testify see none I'm going to close the
public hearing on House Bill one what
was that one
196 190 and I open the public hearing on
House Bill 196 and I invite the prime
sponsor to introduce the bill
you're
in place of the entire bill that is
correct Mr chairman I'll be speaking to
the amendment okay
don't L of pink
tag you you've been gone too long
apparently oh my apologies my apologies
I was running around trying to get the
amendment I forgot to sign up to speak
I'll do that afterwards if that's
okay I'm just waiting for the amendment
to go around just so I can
for e
thank you very much Mr chairman members
of the criminal justice and Public
Safety Committee ranking member goth
representative rhs for some reason this
room feels very familiar I don't quite
know why but it's always good to be back
here and the amendment that I brought
forward to you today thank you for
taking the time to read it I apologize
for that I was hopeful that my amended
Amendment would be in in time for me to
email the committee last night but it
wasn't so I waited for this morning in
time for me to be able to mark it and go
up to O uh HCS and produce some copies
with what the amended Amendment will be
unfortunately not an error of os but an
error of Mind there was on line 25 a
missed word where reads expunged it
should say an olded but I've marked that
on each of your
sheets HP 1996 was brought forward
before the legislature last year last
term by myself and we had in this
committee had some pretty thorough
conversations about what the legislation
was about and moving it forward to the
house floor representative rhods you and
I had a really good debate on the house
floor about it
always and um the legislation itself
what it does is allow people and
initiate the dep Department of Safety to
anull the crime of anyone who has a
possession misdemeanor or violation
level possession charge for cannabis
offenses the point behind the
legislation is similar to
what the spirit behind Governor sununu's
decriminalization law and its annulment
provision was which is the state is
moving forward on this issue as other
states have uh I like to use the example
of Colorado and Washington other states
that moved forward and allowed people to
smoke sell and use this drug but kept
the record of people who had been ared
arrested prior on their record and what
that did was stop them from get loans or
get a job with the federal government or
other programs which restrict people
from getting that job if they have such
a charge on their record these are
people that have served their sentence
done the time come out and now the
charge that they were incarcerated for
in is no longer um being
prosecuted but they're still unable to
get forward in life which is the point
of the Criminal Justice System the
rehabilitation side of it because this
this charge is still on their record so
this
legislation changed from the original
version of hb1 196 would authorize the
department of safety over the course of
the next 18 months after passage to go
through and expunge the record of anyone
who has a misdemeanor or possession
violation level possession offense for
cannabis um it also allows for people if
they
are missed in that 18 months to petition
the court to get an analment it doesn't
allow for anyone to who's currently
serving a sentence get their analment or
anyone who's uh about to be convicted to
not be convicted it doesn't allow for
anyone who has any other charge other
than the misdemeanor violation offense
on their record to to have that an olded
and if you're petitioning for your
analment but you
have but the conviction of a misdemeanor
charge included other charges if you
were arrested for for selling but it
also included misdemeanor possession etc
etc you would not be eligible for
analment this is only for people that
were arrested for violation level and
misdemeanor cannabis
offenses um
currently with the analment statute as
it is where people can petition the
court nobody has gone forward and
petitioned the court we've group of
lawyers have sought people to ask if
they have under the current law because
you can as I said in the beginning under
the current law but they don't and we've
seen in states where this is uh
implemented that people don't go forward
because the form is cumbersome we had
testimony from lawyers who are working
on this issue who said that when they
looked at the form that they're eyes
glazed over because it was uh such a
cumbersome form and I imagine that I
can't imagine that it would be easy for
somebody that uh doesn't have the
background and experience that a lawyer
does to look at that form and and to
seek an analment so what this process
does is make it a proactive process for
annulments
and allow people the opportunity to
petition the court if they feel like
they've been missed from that proactive
process there are 12 states that have
implemented legislation such as Oklahoma
and Utah that goes much Beyond this they
call it uh Clean Slate laws where
essentially the the it's uh much more
thorough wipe of people's records that
is not what we're doing here this is a
very simple proactive measure on one
specific the misdemeanor violation
offenses for for cannabis possession
over the course of people's lifetime um
right now we're not necessarily
Prosecuting those offenses we heard that
in testimony last year but people still
do have it on their record from from
when the state was Prosecuting these so
I think it's good if someone has shown
that they've gone through the criminal
justice system they serve their time to
allow them to move forward in life get
their job get their loan and and have
their record expunged for this crime
which which the state is no longer
Prosecuting in this way that is outlined
in the bill before you here today so
thank you very much for your time Mr
chairman and I'm happy to take any
questions that the committee might have
thank you um I don't see a fiscal note
on this but yet it it mandates um the
department of safety to go back and go
through all these
records did you have or did anyone reach
out to you to say hey that that might
cost some money did did you hear
anything well no doubt will cost some
money I think I would imagine there
would be a fiscal note eventually uh
this is the amendment as it does the
original have the FIS does it anyone
have the original does it have a fiscal
note indeterminable
okay that's not a good thing
um yeah go ahead all right thank you I
was I was curious because it seems to me
that that's it could be Labor
intensitive uh for them to have to go
back through and figure I don't even
know if they have a way to do that um to
search by who has been or has such a
thing on their record
um did you reach out to the Department
of Safety at all to ask about what the
procedure would look like to kind of do
this the department of safety and I had
conversations last year or 20 2024 last
year uh but we haven't had conversations
on on this bill about the specifics I
would say that uh given the number of
these charges that uh I wouldn't say
that there would
be thousands of these charges that they
would have to go through to look at I
wouldn't say it's extraordinarily labor
intensive and I would be open to any
amendment that the committee has around
changing some of those Staffing I'm just
more curious as to whether or not they
have the technology to to I mean i' I've
seen some things that are kind of scary
I don't know if they have if they have
systems that are linked or how how they
would be able to go do that so we'll
reach out to somebody from safety thank
you uh representative Ro you had a
question thank you Mr chairman uh thank
you representative I don't know if I'm
looking at this wrong because it was
just a real quick look over here but
there's a there's a like basically a
page two on the back but it says
about hold on I might be looking at it
says prior to January 25 I was thinking
it was supposed to take
effect but that was getting but carry on
okay question withdrawn um anyone
else representative
Murray thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question um I recently had
some friends of mine who were accepted
to an apartment and then the landlord uh
withdrew his offer after finding out
that 10 years ago one of them had been
charged with possession while he was in
college um and those charges were later
dropped and he was found not guilty but
then it came up on the background report
and so the landlord withdrew the offer
to move into this apartment um would you
believe
that well I'm asking more like do you
think that this bill would address that
slash like that analment clears the
record enough that those kind of
situations wouldn't happen because I
know an nment will still leave something
available on some records you know what
I
mean I can't speak to that specific case
but that's
uh what I would say is the generalities
of that case is why I'm bringing forward
this legislation because you have
situations where people but I'm you know
in doing this legislation I was thinking
more of people in my in my mother's
ation but it's definitely college kids
that were just there as well but people
from you know the 80s and the 90s when
this state was Prosecuting this this
drug a little bit more um intensely a
lot of a lot of bit more intensely um
that it's people go through situations
like that I'm not able to get my
apartment I'm not able to get my loan
I'm not able to get the job that I'm
more than qualified for and they're
looking forward to me being a part of
I've heard anecdotes about that what I
would say is the anulan I think would
that situation there would be things
left there would be a way to look at
past records or you know you can't anull
a uh a newspaper article you know but I
think the fact that the court had come
and said this is anold it gives that
person the ability to go to that
landlord or the uh boss at the job that
they're looking for or the bank and say
yes this did happen but I took the
proactive step and the state assisted in
getting me this annulment so that I have
shown that I've been rehabilitated and
I'm looking to move forward in life as a
citizen participating in this community
in the right
way thank you I think to answer your
question en nment would not be available
for like a landlord or an employee to
see employer but it would remain
available for law enforcement to see if
they were running a background check for
that purposes um representative
Sher just to add to that there is a law
on New Hampshire law I don't have the
the statute number right now that says
uh you can't ask the question have you
ever been convicted of a crime without
asking without attaching that have you
ever been convicted of a crime that
hasn't been an olded so uh that's
another layer to it I think um the
housing issue though might be a federal
thing like if you're applying for
federal housing that yes you would be
barred if you were applying for federal
housing then that that would definitely
be the case yeah exactly
um see no further questions thank you
thank you very much Mr chairman for your
time the committee good to see you as
always the chair calls The Honorable Tom
Manion thank you Mr chair members of the
committee uh so uh you guys in the last
bill you were mentioning the ATF and I
thought that was a really good point and
that comes into play here when we have
the ATF uh form um 4473
where section 21f requires that you
admit whether or not you are a cannabis
user and that that disqualifies you from
purchasing a firearm um so I think the
en nment here is is a great way to
protect your own ass against like
whether or not the atf's going to come
down on you like do a cross search
against whatever may be in your history
about cannabis use when you purchased a
firearm because they can uh flag you as
like for a felony if you lie on this
form five years and like so like coming
from my my persp persective I think that
this bill does a great job of trying to
protect people against uh you know they
may not be aware that cannabis is is
prohibited by the federal government you
can't own a firearm if you're a cannabis
user and with that I'm I'm open any
questions thank you thank you
the chair calls Heather Marie
Brown Heather Marie Brown oh there you
are I promise you will only see me one
other time today besides
now so I my name obviously is Heather
Marie Brown I am here in support of this
bill uh this bill has actually uh this
topic has actually impacted me uh
personally uh so by the time before I
graduated high school I was uh able to
experience a program called the Epsom
earn and learn program uh what that
program did was it took High School uh
students that were close to graduation
and it gave them training in the field
of uh certified nursing assistance with
a specialty in geriatric care uh it had
always been a lifelong dream of mine
ever since I was a small child to be
involved in the medical field even now I
still dream of being involved in the
medical field uh by the time I was uh
before I even graduated high school I
was licensed by the state of New
Hampshire as a certified nursing
assistant my plan was to experience that
and to work in that realm for a few
years and then use the abilities that
the job gave me to be able to pursue a
um a better career in nursing my goal
was to take each of the steps necessary
to move up the ladder so that ultimately
I could be in a wonderful position where
I was working hand inand with patients
and I was giving that love and comfort
and support and medical care that I so
desperately wanted to give
uh unfortunately because of a couple of
cannabis arrests uh one of them included
uh this was probably my favorite um I
had a bowl on me and I was not charged
with paraphernalia I was charged with
possession because the bowl was dirty so
therefore I was in possession of
cannabis it made the charge a little
heavier and a little bit more
substantial and it sure cost me a lot
more money in the long run um so I have
a couple of small arrests on my record I
was extremely excited when the first
bill passed and that it became a
possibility for me to possibly get an
analment because that meant that I could
continue moving forward in the medical
field um unfortunately when you have
drug convictions you're they really
frown upon that and you're not allowed
to move forward in in that area
um so when the law went into effect I I
looked into it and I've looked into it a
few times in hopes that maybe the
process had changed but it was such a
long and meticulous and
ridiculously Indescribable process to be
able to go through it even with working
with the court with the clerks at the
courthouse there was still confusion
from them and the bottom line was that
it was going to cost me more money
because of having to file with the
courts and then having to file with this
person and that person and this person
it was going to cost me more money that
I just unfortunately didn't have I am
considered a low-income individual in
the state I wish that my circumstances
were different but they weren't so it
became a choice do I get my record
analed or do I pay my bills for this
month and keep a roof over my head or do
I buy groceries or things like that I
think that that this bill and and I hate
to use the term but it's almost like a
cleanup bill it alleviates those
problems that stood in the way I know
absolutely no one that has been able to
utilize the analment process and
actually get some place with it um this
cleans it up this allows for people to
get a second chance this allows someone
such as
myself to possibly move forward into
better my circumstances and create a
better future and outcome for my
children you know there there are all
sorts of studies out there that show
that children brought up in low-income
families they have less chances at a
better future unfortunately and you know
that's something I never wanted to pass
on to my children or my family um I want
to be able to get my charges inal I want
to be able to move forward with my life
I want to be able to seek out housing
employment and even education I couldn't
even attend some of the courses I wanted
to attend because of that criminal
aspect record of mine so I hope that you
will support this bill I hope you'll
vote it and move it forward and I think
that it'll have a huge impact and really
be able to change the lives of so many
individuals within the
state thank you um see no questions
thank you for your
testimony sh calls uh Dr
H good
afternoon um Joe Hannah again um it's
been said a lot so I'll probably be
brief on those but we know about public
housing student loans limited job
opportunities professional lure that's
been denied but um you know the only
reason we've been here discussing this
is because cannabis laws have been
uh not strictly enforced across the
country across
demographics and the people that do get
arrested for it and have convictions are
absolutely in the minority of people who
use cannabis in 2021 it was estimated
there were 52 and a half million people
in the US about 19% of Americans had
used cannabis at least once uh that
number was substantially higher for
those between 19 and
30 in federal prisons there were only in
federal courts there were only 145
Federal simple possession offenders in
that had been convicted at all in the
whole country out of 51 52 and a half
million people that were using it so
we're talking a very small number at the
federal level most of the people that
were in jail are at the state level
obviously um in 22 the president at the
time pardoned uh all simple possession
charges I believe and there were a total
and dating back I think I forget the
year was many many years they went back
to the early 90s or 80s even and it was
about 6,557
people that were pardoned uh those
pardons have continued at the the
presidential level but states have also
uh gone out of their way to to write
this wrong um we wouldn't have any we
wouldn't be having any legalization
bills any discussion on this whatsoever
if it was strictly enforce President
Lincoln said the best way to get a bad
law repealed is to enforce it strictly
this law has been stepped around and
tiptoed and we only arrest certain
people that aren't going to complain and
make a big stink we've had how many
presidents have admitted to smoking
cannabis or even doing stronger drugs
like cocaine or other drugs if they had
been arrested would they have been if
they had been arrested and convicted
would any of those individuals be
president how many CEOs wouldn't be a
CEO of a company or how many doctors or
nurses wouldn't be practicing and
helping people and saving lives um we
are going over a very we're you think
we're just you know granting amnesty to
everyone who's been convicted but you
and I most of us in this room were not
those people or may may have been but
they they don't Target um people that
are going to come to conquered and stand
up to fight for themselves usually they
don't they don't Target people who are
going to make us stink and I think it's
wrong that we have this uh law that says
you know we're not going to charge you
and throw you into prison we're just
going to give you a fine now and we're
still going to say that's that stain
should be on your record like a Scarlet
Letter and everyone should know about it
so you can't get a job you know you walk
down the street and see a homeless
person and we go well why don't they get
a job why don't they get off their feet
you know they can't get public housing
they can't get a college education
student loan you know we make it harder
to keep people down because of these so
the very least we can do is to anull the
convictions of people who are at The
Fringe of society as far as convictions
are concerned the number of people using
cannabis it's hypocritical to even put
one person in jail or 6500 some people
in jail in federal prisons over many
years when we've had millions and
millions of people using this with
impunity in some cases and I'm not going
to talk about specifics but I was you
know I've talked to reps who was said
well I was a kid and you know we got
pulled over and no they didn't find the
they they found the marijuana they let
us go luckily didn't find our cocaine
you know I've heard these stories from
people in not this room none of you
don't get upset um I've heard these
stories not just one but multiple
stories like that from people elected to
office they wouldn't have been here if
that police officer says well you look
like a you know like a troublemaker or
someone I don't particularly like the
looks of so I'm going to arrest you for
this simple possession offense they
didn't even know about the cocaine they
ared them for that and they wouldn't be
here today so I I think about you know
we've all made mistakes in our lives if
if I had been convicted if I got charged
for any of the stuff I did as a teenager
you know luckily most of us in here were
not didn't have video cameras when we
were in high school and college um but
think about what would you do today if
your life had been drastically changed
what would you what would you be like
today if you had a conviction at a young
age or even you know now would you want
that to stand for a for a crime that is
no longer a crime in some in some
situations or is just a misdemeanor in
the state and I I'd like you to think
about that personally and vote
accordingly I'd be happy to take any
questions uh for for what it's worth uh
a few years ago not too many years ago
um I did a study uh I looked at um all
the licensing boards in the state of New
Hampshire uh to see what questions they
asked about criminal
convictions uh it was revealing in that
many many uh uh asked question would
would not uh
allow uh uh a li to Grant a license uh
if you had any criminal conviction like
if you
were Wilderness guide and you had a
criminal conviction you couldn't get a
license since then as a part A a result
of that study the uh uh the licensing
organization in the state um the office
of Licensing I forgot the acronym has
gone through all the licensing board
application
and they've made a significant number of
changes as to what if any criminal
convictions they're even going to ask
about so um I I just want to get that
out on the table so you know that I I'd
love to believe that I I think I I I I
believe you I'm not doubting you but I
so is that true I I I you're the expert
I believe it
uh so the answer is I would believe him
thank you um but I also I also think
that it's important to to realize that
um it's not just the professional
licenser there's a stigma associated
with it you know um we love to hang the
you know we've seen people say oh
they're a felon whatever it it changes
your opinion of someone and that changes
not just those concrete things we
mentioned like jobs and housing but it
it changes how we interact with people
in society unfortunately and I think
that's very important that we get away
from that uh none of us is better than
anybody else I don't think we should you
know labels are bad enough we don't need
uh Scarlet letters hanging around your
neck for the rest of I mean there was a
book about it I had to read it in grade
school or middle middle school and it's
still there we we're not we've not
gotten rid of that concept for like I
said we're talking about very few people
that get the people that get convicted
are not the average person if they
arrested everybody that did it it
wouldn't be against the law because
they'd all be riding in the streets
chair
calls Sergeant
catalo sorry I she told me Sergeant it's
Lieutenant got demoted
apologies chairman members of the
committee my uh written testimony is
being passed around it is in reference
to the original bill so feel free to
read it but a lot of that is uh now moot
um I'm here on behalf of New Hampshire
association's Chiefs of police and uh we
are opposed to this bill I had a chance
to look over the amended um bill which
I'll speak to now um so we would still
be opposed to this and and the primary
reason is the implementation of sweeping
annulments for Mr meter and violation um
level offenses for cannabis uh first of
all there's already an analment law that
I'm sure you're all aware of um that
allows people to petition and receive an
analment for the decriminalized amount
um which is 3/4 of an ounce 21 Grams um
we feel that's
inappropriate law in the books it's
already addressed and people have the
opportunity to do that um the sweeping
analment of all misdemeanor and
violation level offenses
is in our view not the purpose of
annulments which we believe are for
people who are seeking Rehabilitation to
move on with their lives to take steps
to do that doing this widespread
analment um kind of Loops everybody in
people that may have had numerous
offenses extensive criminal records um
you really don't know the people that
you're analing where the process we have
now in the law that is on the books is
much more Case by casee and intentional
um and we just feel that's far more
appropriate I haven't had a chance to
read this bill in depth but that's for
what I have seen so far um what I'm
comfortable testifying to at this point
any questions I'll be happy to
answer thank you we heard testimony that
the current en nment process can be both
expensive and complicated what is your
understanding of that I obviously
haven't I haven't been through it um
reading it I mean it seems pretty
straight forward it allows for petition
to the court what happens after that
petition um I'm not sure if it if that
is the case and that could be addressed
separately than making it simpler making
it easier making it more accessible to
people rather than this kind of what I
feel is a more drastic step is these
sweeping annulments um which like you
said chairman puts which another issue
puts quite a bit of bonus on the
department of safety to do which I'm not
even sure would be fully possible I
don't I'm not sure that they would be
able to do it either um and to your
point so if someone could be
theoretically an active um
not only drug user but involved in
various crimes and automatically
received this analment is that your
understanding uh reading the bill I have
in front of me and it was in the
testimony yeah these are seems pretty
clear convictions and arrest for Mr M
violation pH possession of cannabis
prior to the January 1st date shall be
annulled um with no qualifiers as far as
um criminal records ongoing Behavior
anything like
that thank you any further questions
yes representative
pette thank you I just have a quick
question um it says remove misdemeanor
and violation level offenses what is the
difference between those two as it
applies to this specifically so
misdemeanor would be like as the law
stands now it's anything above that 3/4
of an ounce would be an arrest so 21
gram which I mean anyone's familiar with
usual level amounts of marijuana I mean
I think people typically smoke half a
gram up to a couple grams at a time so
if people are in possession of over 21
gram that is quite a significant amount
um and that would be the misdemeanor
anything below that right now is a
violation which is essentially a ticket
similar what you get when you do traffic
infractions those are also violations um
so this bill would anull not only the
violations but all the misdemeanors for
people in possession of above that thank
you if you're aware do they uh is is a
private company or an employee or
anything like that do they have access
to violations on a record check not that
I'm aware of I I can't speak firmly on
that sir but uh not that I'm aware of
right now okay thank you
you uh Rich you question okay all right
thank you for your testimony thank you
sir is there anyone else wishing to
testify on this bill who has not
testified or filled out a card seeing
none I hereby Clos this public hearing
we will reconvene it one
e
e e
could ask everybody to find their seats
we can settle in to start our
afternoon public
hearings good all right
I am opening the hearing for House Bill
198 and I welcome the sponsor
representative
Sullivan introduce the
bill hi there U Madam chair thank you
for taking my my uh testimony and
presentation of the bill so um for those
of you that were here last year we all
know there was a bit of drama and back
and forth with respect to cannabis
legalization in New Hampshire and so you
know I um wanted to take the lead on
trying to
legalize for
possession Legalize It In the state but
this does not deal with the selling so
what I learned through this journey of
the last couple years is that many
people in New Hampshire and in this body
and even on the other side of the aisle
in the Senate they they um by and large
seem to be supportive of no longer
arresting people and
um essentially ruining certain people's
lives for something that by and large
many people in our society have grown to
accept the the consumption of of
cannabis by by responsible adults but it
remains illegal in New Hampshire we're
an island in New England and so the goal
here is to not get caught up in what has
been our stumbling block for the last
well two years that I've been here but
also prior to that is how we sell it and
regulate it so this doesn't touch that
the goal of this is simply to legalize
this and allow for uh reasonable
quantities of possession which is 2
ounces um it's it prohibits things like
smoking in public I spoke to some
Senators when I was drafting this and
they were concerned about public smoking
so I put that in here uh hopefully that
will appease some of the concerns that
some people have with respect to people
smoking and potentially secondhand smoke
and then uh some of the concerns that
come from that with respect to uh public
consumption of cannabis um I think it's
important to understand this language is
very similar almost identical to the
language that the house passed and sent
to the Senate last year and then was
sent back to us um for the concur motion
at the end of last term uh in terms of
the legalization bill so this this is
very similar language with very minor
tweaks and uh also there is precedent
for this method where we legalize
without without regulating how to sell
it first Vermont did the same thing they
they actually legalized it and a few
years later came back with a regulatory
framework on how they would allow
license and then regulate the sale of
cannabis in the state and so my goal
here again is to stop arresting people
and locking up people who are who are
not committing violent crimes who are
really just consuming something that is
legal in every surrounding piece of land
whether it's main Canada Vermont or
Massachusetts and is is generally
considered by most in our Society to not
be as harmful as uh it was thought to be
in times past and importantly the
majority of people in New Hampshire do
support legalization and don't like the
idea of locking up people for the
possession of cannabis in New Hampshire
so this would put an end to that
practice and I hope that um you guys
will uh be supportive of it and I will
take any
questions thank you for your testimony
representative
well look at you getting off
easy thank you very much see no
questions thank you very
much representative
Howard thank you honorable Madam chair
and uh committee members uh thank you
for having me back again uh my name is
representative Heath Howard I repres
pres the towns of straford and barington
and straford District 4 uh I'm here in
support of HB 198 because it legalizes
the possession of 2 oz of cannabis for
recreational use uh for people 21 years
of age and older uh but it also creates
penalties for smoking and vaping in
public it does not legalize the sale of
cannabis it does not allow people to
operate Vehicles while inebriated under
the effects of cannabis nor does it
allow for cannabis to be grown uh
essentially this bill is a legalization
bill for home use only with the express
goal of protecting people uh for simple
possessions for uh situations like
during traffic stops this is not my
preferred method of legalization but it
is a basic compromise that maintains the
public Norms while also giving people
new individual liberties to use on
private property if somebody is caught
smoking or vaping in public they can
face a fine uh starting at $100 going
all the way up to to a Class B
misdemeanor depending on uh how many
offenses there are in a three-year
period uh that maintains the current
status quo and personally I mean I think
it's a little bit excessive but uh
especially For Vaping where there
there's minimal smell uh but again it's
trying to reach out across the aisle and
get something through so that we can
actually legalize the substance because
there is very minimal uh public safety
risk uh with that being said uh I'm open
to any question questions thank
you seeing none oh change your mind
representative
news can you talk a little bit about how
the bill uh treats people under the age
of 18 and and and what protections it
includes for them yeah uh so obviously
because this is a legalization Bill uh
this still does have uh illegality for
people under the age of 18 uh let me try
and find that real quick um there might
be somebody who could uh better talk to
this at off the top of my head because
it was the one thing that I didn't write
down um any person who's under the age
of 18 who is convicted of uh violating
uh paragraph 45 shall forfeit cannabis
uh and shall be subject to delinquency
petition under RSA 169
B6 uh so it does I I'm not sure uh off
the top of my head how that changes the
current
law apologies
sorry so this is my fourth term and I
haven't run into a delinquency petition
yet uh as a potential penalty can do you
uh do you know any more about that than
I do uh somebody might be better uh able
to address that thank
you representative Sher I'll try and put
this in the form of a question um
so would you know that a delinquency
petition is a um uh it's it's the
juvenile equivalent of charging someone
with a crime so uh if you want to charge
a juvenile someone under the age 18 with
a crime you file a juvenile petition um
and it's adjudicated in that fashion
there's more deadlines uh but that's the
that's what a juvenile petition is well
thank you you know
that I I I clearly was not as prepared
as I should have been
sorry anyone else
good you
good
yes so at the age of 18 does that go
away no uh it's confidential um it
doesn't go away but it's confidential
it's different than an analment
uh you're uh it can't be revealed okay
thank
you thank you
representative
okay page the
bottom oops uh
page two uh section uh page two um line
33 uh it look or I'm sorry line 36 it
does say uh that there is a they are
they also will be subject to a fine of
$100 for first or second offense uh and
a fine of up to 300 for any subsequent
offense so there is a penalty yeah okay
yes that that that is the current
penalty uh right now okay thank
you all right thank you very much
representative thank I'll see
you is there a Mr riddle
here
score welcome Madam chair members of the
committee my name is Jim Riddle
Hillsboro uh New Hampshire I serve on
the board of the New Hampshire cannabis
Association as well as on the policy and
education Committee of the north east
organic Farmers Association of New
Hampshire I serve on the Hillsboro
Conservation Commission and am moderator
of the Emerald Lake Village District but
I offer comments today on my own behalf
in support of uh House Bill 198 and
there two things I like about uh the
bill right off the top it doesn't create
any new bureaucracy and it doesn't cost
taxpayers any
money um I think we can all agree that
the state of New Hampshire doesn't
really like to establish or maintain
bureaucracy um I mean the Department of
Agriculture markets and uh food
mismanaged an organic state run Organic
certification program till it was
finally closed down last year and as you
may recall there was a bill last year to
legalize cannabis that would have cost
taxpayers $18
million to establish a Soviet style
statun cannabis Monopoly and I want to
thank you for rejecting that bad idea by
the way um but if instead of
establishing new bureaucracy House Bill
198 essentially raises the Cannabis
possession limit from 3/4 of an ounce to
2 ounces it prohibits smoking or vaping
vaping in public and makes it clear that
miners cannot legally possess cannabis
and while the bill does not establish a
legal Market or support business
investment here in New Hampshire or
provide a way to tax cannabis it's
important to take a moment to uh review
some of the experiences of states that
have establish legal cannabis markets St
such states have brought in tens of
millions of dollars in tax revenue
they've seen increases in jobs in
tourism in business investment and given
young people a reason to stay in those
States in state after state with legal
cannabis youth cannabis use has actually
Fallen it's
true along with the rates of opioid
overdoses and deaths another interesting
thing in Ohio which recently established
a legal Market the Department of Public
Safety reported a 30% decrease in
traffic fatalities in the first year uh
of having an adult used cannabis market
so those are some of the real life
impacts that are happening with legal
cannabis in other
states well this bill HB 198 will not
establish a cannabis
Market but it does recognize the fact
that many Granite Staters purchase
cannabis in Maine Vermont and
Massachusetts and bring it back to New
Hampshire now we may not want tax
revenue or increases in tourism or
business Investments but we can at least
save money on unnecessary and harmful
enforcement actions this is an efficient
Bill and it needs to pass and let the
citizens of New Hampshire live free
thank
you thank you very much or any
questions seeing none thank you very
much Matt Simon
thank you madam chair for the record
Matt Simon I work for granite Leaf
cannabis this bill doesn't have anything
to do with the therapeutic cannabis
program it wouldn't have any impact on
the atcs uh we support it as a matter of
principle and I'm going to make a few
brief comments uh that come more from my
experience working on this issue in New
Hampshire and in other states so I think
one thing New Hampshire has learned in
the last couple years is that uh
cannabis legalization is not a yes or no
question we often hear it presented as a
yes or no question in the media when a
pollster calls somebody and asks do you
support legalizing cannabis it's
presented as a yes or no question but
every actual cannabis legalization Bill
contains typically dozens of policy
choices some of which may be good or bad
all of which are debatable and many
bills get derailed over people not being
able to agree on those dozens of policy
choices so I had the privilege several
years ago of working on the legalization
campaigns in Vermont worked closely with
the Vermont state legislature as they
became the first state legislature to
legalize cannabis and we went through
this in Vermont uh there were a number
of bills trying to regulate cannabis
there were a lot of interests that had
opinions about how cannabis should be
regulated there was a lot of difficulty
reaching in consensus on this all the
previous States had just done it through
ballot initiatives where those policy
choices were made by the drafters of the
initiative and then voters had a yes or
no question in front of them doing it
through the state legislature makes it a
lot more complicated to build consensus
so when Vermont failed a couple of bills
they went back to the drawing board and
said actually what do we all agree on we
all agree that vermers should not be
punished if they're adults for
possessing cannabis so they passed their
first legal Iz ation bill was very
similar to this it did include home
cultivation which this bill doesn't this
bill only applies to personal possession
but the idea was stop punishing people
we all agree on that and once we pass
that hopefully everybody will come to
the table and we won't be arguing over
legalization anymore we'll be arguing
over how to regulate cannabis properly
and Vermont did two years later pass
what I consider to be the best cannabis
regulation law in in the country uh I'm
hopeful that New Hampshire could take
the same path uh if this bill goes to
the other chamber or if if a complex
bill goes to the other chamber there
will be dozens of policy choices that
could derail that other Bill if this
simple bill goes to the other chamber it
really is a yes or no question do you
think adults in the Live Free or dies
date should be punished for possession
and so I think this is a good bill both
strategically as well as on policy
uh turning briefly to uh the questions
about under 21 my understanding is that
this bill doesn't change the existing
policies uh I worked with this committee
back in uh
2017 on on the bill that ultimately
became law decriminalizing up to 3/4 of
an ounce of cannabis and at that time we
had a very robust and detailed
discussion about what that should mean
for people under 18 and for under 21
what is the most appropriate
intervention if not criminalization and
with buyin from a lot of organizations
from a lot of different perspectives we
reached the compromise that is now law
and I believe it's exactly what you see
before you that under 18 is a
delinquency
petition uh the most appropriate way of
dealing with that and for anybody 18 and
older it would be a violation so this
maintains that violation for 18 19 and
20y olds it would still be the violation
that it currently is under DCM and it
simply eliminates the the violation for
people over 21 uh and changes the amount
I believe but other than that I think
it's pretty straightforward I think it's
consistent with uh New Hampshire's
decriminalization law a logical next
step forward and preventing Granite
Staters from being put into the criminal
justice system for simply possessing
cannabis
that's all I have happy to take any
questions representative
PR just
curious when I drink alcohol I pulled
over there's a test to say whether I
should be driving or not is there one
for cannabis yet there is not
yeah representative pette I have a
question that's kind of related um it
says in here um you you know you can't
drive under the influence so this
clearly says that but um you know if
you're in your car are you in your
personal property or are you in public
like public is a no personal property is
a yes if you're in your car somewhere
cuz you know we've all been there and
then you know been somewhere driving and
then there's you know huge puff of
smokes coming out of the car and now
it's in yours I mean how how does that
work with this
I'm going to leave that one for an
attorney I
will yeah I don't I don't have an easy
answer on that I will note that New
Hampshire has other laws for example
last year the oper container law that
passed this committee added cannabis to
the open container statute so simply
possessing an unsealed container of
cannabis anywhere in a motor vehicle is
a violation and that comes with a
possible driver's license suspension so
I happen to strongly disagree with that
law but did not test against it that's
another issue it is illegal elsewhere in
the criminal code to drive while
impaired on any substance we have
breathalyzers that are trusted for
alcohol for every other drug we do not
have either a specific legal limit that
is accepted by science or a specific way
of testing for it other than a blood
test which gets you to a conviction
every other state has gone through this
discussion of what impaired driving
policies may need to change in light of
legalization two points that I'll make
one there is no evidence that
prohibition has been effective in
deterring use so New Hampshire has one
of the highest cannabis consumption
rates in the country and we had that
before decrim we had that before medical
cannabis it's because we're in New
England and new englanders smoke more
cannabis than people in the Southeast it
has nothing to do with policy so the
expectation was that use would increase
dramatically after legalization I think
it's pretty clear that hasn't happened
there have been modest increases in use
that have mostly been among the older
population the population where use has
increased most in states that have
tracked it it's it's the over 50 crowd
and the over 65 crowd more than young
people as Mr riddle said the evidence is
overwhelming that that miners are
actually using less cannabis uh in the
wake of legalization so often causing
effect or counterintuitive but it's
already illegal to drive while impaired
and we have a process for convi
convicting people it involves uh
officers who are trained as drug
recognition experts and if somebody's
thought to be impaired by any substance
other than alcohol we have a process for
getting that person convicted and off
the roads and that will be the same
process whether cannabis is legal or
decriminalized or illegal uh would be
the same thank you representative Shear
you are recognized for a
question
answer go
you very proud of myself we so
excited thank you is there any other
questions no thank all right thank
you Dr Hannon
uh thank you again um for for hearing me
today uh Joe Hannon and uh I'm not going
to speak for very long I promise um even
though I could but 1954 Robert
borenstein invented the breathalyzer it
was 21 years after prohibition was
repealed uh just for historical
references there uh like it's been said
this bill has basically gotten rid of
most of the contentious issues that had
been a problem in the last 10 years that
I 10 plus years that I've been doing
this I was on the commission back in 18
and uh the number one uh the the biggest
issues were how are we going to get it
to people um this does what uh you know
it solves that problem it doesn't do it
and I I think we should just pass this
bill if you have any questions I'd be
happy to answer them I'm really not
going to talk anymore I promise unless
he ask me a question then I'll all
right
thanks none all right seeing none thank
you is there anybody here that wishes to
testify on House Bill 198 that has not
turned in a pain card seeing none I am
closing the public hearing for house bow
198 and let's see what time it
is I wish we could
just so anybody that's here our next
hearing is not scheduled until
2:30 uh we apologize but we do have to
stick to this
um hearing schedule so if anybody does
want to testify they have the
opportunity to do that so uh the
committee will be in recess until
2:30
e
e e
good afternoon it again um so it is now
2:30 our little recess is is
over is everybody ready to go okay I so
I'm going to open the public hearing for
House Bill
226 and recognize is there somebody here
Representative no you're going to
introduce the legislation for us oh it
is your legislation Representative no I
sure
am all right thank you madam chair and
thanks to the committee for your time
and consideration today for the record
my name is jod n and I represent chesher
for and Kean some of you will remember
this bill um that last term uh a similar
bill was proposed we created a
subcommittee we poured over the details
brought in stakeholders and experts and
ultimately passed that bill out of
committee and through the Full House
unfortunately that bill died in the
Senate so here we are uh due to the
importance though of implementing this
policy we decided to take a really good
look at the concerns expressed and adapt
so this uh this is the resulting bill
that we have here
today it's 2025 and while we have done
an extraordinary job uh of building out
our uh system of substance use
prevention treatment recovery and harm
reduction we are still losing loved ones
to overdose too many people have been
lost and too many people are still
struggling still at risk one important
element of a comprehensive harm
reduction strategy involves the ability
to anal analyze substances on our
streets in fact much of the rest of our
system depends on a complete accurate
and dynamic understanding of exactly
what is on our streets and where while
we were able to pass venal and xylazine
test strip decriminalization last year
this provides very limited information
so I'd like to direct technical
questions um to our experts who will be
speaking after me but to briefly explain
a test strip identifies the presidence
the presence of a substance and only
that one substance that it is um
intended to identify it does not measure
measure how much of that substance is
present or whether any other substances
are present fortunately uh there are
tools for a more deep analysis this bill
would allow for organizations registered
with DHHS to use this equipment in order
to gain more information about what is
on our streets and with that help to
Target assistance where needed
ultimately saving precious lives so I
thought it would be helpful um to work
my way through the bill and kind of um
just so we can understand what uh what
is in here and why um so starting out
what it um it changes it to drug
paraphernalia um on page two lines 13
through 16 uh what we're doing is we're
amending in order to draw a clear
distinction between what uses and
intended purposes drug testing equipment
is allowable for and what it is not
allowable
for um on page two lines 17 through 26
um this is a bit of rearranging in order
to uh add additional exemptions but I
want to note that we maintain the
language that was passed in 2023 through
the house and through the Senate
ultimately signed into law by the
governor which is decriminalizing fenal
and xylazine test test strips and adding
the conditions uh and the conditions
under which that exemption was made now
apply to the rest that we are
adding um on page two lines 30 through
36 this is where we carve out an
exemption for uh drug checking equipment
um the necessary materials when used by
agents
um of organizations that are explicitly
authorized by state county municipality
or a public health
department um on page
three lines 1 through 26 um at this
point we needed to add some more uh
further definitions including drug
checking drug drug checking equipment
drug checking packaging eligible
activities and harm reduction for the
purposes of this
section um on page three lines 20 27
through 36 uh here we are clarifying
that drug checking equipment or
materials used for this purpose would
not be considered drug paraphernalia
only when used by harm reduction
programs registered with um New
Hampshire
DHHS um on page four actually um we have
I've put in for an amendment because
there was uh something that we left in
here that we wanted to um take out and
um but this is where we affirmative
affirmatively state that drug checking
is permitted in this context wait
representative can can you hold on just
one second I just want
to I think she got okay okay um so on
page four this is where we affirmatively
state that drug checking is permitted in
this context that the state may allocate
funding including opioid abatement funds
um and federal funds intended for this
purpose we clarify that no person
engaging in drug checking under these
circumstances and by by this we mean
employees of the organizations that we
explicitly State uh should be able to do
this uh that none of them should should
be penalized for engaging in drug
checking work and that the results of
drug checking analysis should not be
used for nefarious purposes um in this
section I just want to note let me see
it is on page four line S uh I actually
just put in for an amend they said if it
wasn't ready by 2:30 that it would be
shortly after um and what that Amendment
would do would take out online seven on
page four um a nominal amount of one or
more Controlled Substances or controlled
substance analog analoges um and we we
didn't mean for that to be in there the
point is that this would be uh just for
harm reduction organizations public
health organizations and the employees
thereof um so we did not intend for that
uh to be in there so we've just made a a
quick correction to that um and I think
um I think that's about
it I'm happy to take any
questionsa could you just point me there
was something you had just said and I
was trying to read it but I was
highlighting something else yeah um it
was one of the last sentences you had
mentioned about I think it was was the
am like the amount you said nominal yes
so we had intended I'm sorry what was
that the one you said you're fixing or
that's the amendment yeah that's the one
that we're taking out so what it is is
that we we do want to allow for um
employees of organizations who are
tasked with this um to be able to
transport so all of the things that that
are included in in drug checking
materials and that is included in what
is allowable by employees of this
organization explicitly for that purpose
um but not for anyone not for anyone who
is coming to have their um have tested
thank you so I I hadn't realized that it
wasn't it wasn't in that section that it
wasn't only for those folks and so yeah
so we put in an amendment for it already
and should have it back what what
section is that in here me just to make
a not so that is on page four okay line
seven starting on line seven and going
into line eight um so it would strike um
a nom nominal amount of one or more
Controlled Substances or controlled
substance analoges I see it thank you
okay and then I just have um another
question real fast if if I may yeah sure
so I'm looking at page
three and it is on line 11 and it's
basically the very end be like the next
sentence drug checking equipment does
not include the substance being analyzed
drug packaging or drug
supplies
so so can you explain how that would
work if it's you know if this if this
person clearly has drugs on them and
then they have they just they have some
drug checking equipment like what like
what would that look like or what does
drug supplies
mean so right here what we're talking
about is what fits under the the
definition of drug checking equipment so
it's clarifying that that does not fit
under the definition of um drug checking
equipment
thank you representative okay are there
any questions for Representative
no see none thank you very much got off
easy all right
run thank you representative
celik morning or good afternoon Hello
friends it's nice to see you again um
for the record I am Lauren selig and I
represent straford 10 which is the town
of Durham New Hampshire um and one of
the things that I think many people
forget about when they talk about this
committee being the committee of
Criminal Justice is the second half of
the name which is the public safety
component it's criminal justice and
Public Safety and when I think about
Public Safety a large part of that is
making sure that people stay alive and
and are able to stay alive and be well
um we know that we have people who
unfortunately suffer from addiction and
to various substances and in different
kinds of
ways and we can't help them if they're
not alive right if they overdose and die
there's no more that we can do to help
them get to a space of recovery around
their addiction or anything else so when
I look at this bill and when we worked
on it last year and I remember how very
hard we worked on this bill to get it
through um I think about that this is a
goal intended for the public safety
component to help people who suffer from
addiction make sure that what they're
using isn't filled with things that they
aren't aware of that are likely to kill
them or increase the likelihood of their
dying on that particular day because if
they live one more day we have a much
better chance of helping them get to a
place of being ready for Recovery um
interestingly as I was thinking about
what comments I wanted to make today in
front of all of you I was also looking
at my social media feed from a year ago
I had posted about being proud of our
committee for having passed this bill
and moving forward but also on this day
one year ago in Littleton New Hampshire
we had three young people in their 20s
all succumb to addiction um they
overdosed as a group um because of a
substance that had been in there in the
drugs that they were using they drugs
they were choosing to use were full of
things they weren't aware were in there
that led to their overdose and death and
so I really hope that you pass this bill
I encourage you to continue to support
it um and to help it succeed through the
Senate ideally this time as well so we
can get it to the governor's desk for
the purposes of of helping people in the
greater public
thank
you representative
Muse thank you my name is uh
representative David Muse I represent
Rockingham uh 37 the communities of
Portsmouth Newcastle uh and Newington
and I'm testifying in uh in support of
this
bill um in New Hampshire we've been
dealing with an opioid crisis for much
of the past decade and uh this is one of
the first years I think when we've
really been able to report um that we
have made some sub substantial progress
so last year according to the latest
count that I had in 20124 we
unfortunately had 199 opioid deaths in
New Hampshire uh in 202 two that was uh
the the total was
430 so in a 2-year period we actually
managed to cut that in half which is a
tremendous accomplishment and one of the
things that's happened as a result is
people are scratching their heads going
well what's what's going on what's the
factor what was the Silver Bullet and I
think the conclusion that a lot of
people are are coming to is it wasn't
necessarily any one Silver Bullet it was
the fact that one of the things we did
in New Hampshire that was very
successful was we adopted an all of the
above
strategy so um one of the things that
law enforcement did is it targeted um
Mexican cartels us Distributors uh law
enforcement community in New Hampshire
is Tred to make life very difficult for
individuals who want to sell people
Fentanyl and other opioids um harm
reduction uh Services um things like
expansion of the availability of nxone
uh so so more people who overdose uh
have rapid access and in time uh to a
drug that can save their lives um has
has made a difference um dealers and
manufacturers may also finally uh be
starting to discover that killing your
customers uh isn't a great way to
conduct your conduct your business so
one of the things that has been
happening is uh the the tremendous
amounts of fentanyl uh that were just
commonly found in in fatal quantities
uh very very commonly in the drug Supply
still we'll find that not quite as
common as it was a few as as it was a
few years ago so there are a lot of
things that are coming together to to
make things better um I think the thing
that we need to keep in mind is just
because things are getting better it
doesn't mean it's time to take our foot
off the gas pedal um we're still in a
crisis uh there are still people dying
and there's plenty of work left to do so
one of the things that this bill would
do in particular particular that would
be just tremendously beneficial is that
currently when we want to legalize a new
uh piece of drug checking equipment like
fentanyl test strips or xylazine test
strips like we did a couple of years ago
the way that our statute is written we
actually have to add that in statute so
last year when I testified in front of
you uh I told you about a drug called
Zine uh which is a new fentanyl analog
uh two to 50 times more more powerful
than fentanyl which is not detected on
fentanyl test strips and at the time I
said well gee if if a a test strip was
available for this particular drug Z
zidine you know it it would save lives
but the problem we're running into in
New Hampshire is that if we can't put it
in our statute then some the some of the
public health uh professionals you know
who are doing the testing and are trying
to get this stuff out into the community
you know might be at risk of violating
the law so um rather than having a
always have to get together as a
committee for every one of these
innovations that comes along um one of
the things that this bill would do is it
would legalize uh Innovations in drug
checking as a class so for instance if a
new test strip was available the tested
for Zine um then it could instantly be
deployed in in a way that that that
could save lives if a test STP was
available that could test across
multiple drugs uh and and show a return
we would be able to deploy that
instantaneously without worrying about
uh any potential violations of the law
so one of the things that it just does
is it makes our statute easier easier to
work with and more responsive to to
Scientific
Innovations one of the other things that
this particular Bill does is is it also
would legalize opioid reversal agents as
a class so nxone is an opioid reversal
agent it it's very effective uh against
Fentanyl and other types of opioids less
effective uh with with other drugs there
are uh new opioid reversal a uh opioid
reversal agents that are uh currently uh
under FDA testing that are just about
ready to be released uh that could make
a difference there there are some people
who might not be able to be revived with
no oxone um so one of the things that
again we're trying to do is as these
Innovations become available we want our
of law to be a facilitator uh and not a
barrier when it when it comes to saving
lives um the addition the issue that we
had last year with a with a nominal
amount was something that we kind of
work through in this committee it proved
to be a showstopper over in the Senate
and I know there's been a lot of uh a
lot of issues with it on the part of the
law enforcement Community but when we
talk about a la a nominal amount it's
it's the idea that uh what are you
putting on that fenal test strip um and
and and so and so last year the idea was
well gee what we'll what we'll do is
we'll just we you know we won't include
that for prosecution uh it's like a like
a 10 milligram or less thing we we went
back and forth should we Define it how
do we Define it and and and the problem
was is um the reality is you need some
level of these drugs to test but I think
the issue is is we don't want to be in a
position where we're ever really
legalizing any amount of a controlled
controlled substance so one of the
things that we're doing you know that we
want to try to do this year is to uh is
to uh to amend the bill so that
essentially uh people who actually work
in testing so public health
professionals um they won't have any
legal exposure for testing the drug same
as like people in our State Police lab
we don't want them to have exposure if
they're testing drugs either uh on the
on the other hand um uh one of the
things that sometimes you have to kind
of uh uh agree to disagree or or um
that's probably not the best way to the
best way to put it but I think I think
sometimes you just have to come to a
realization um that uh that a small
Minor Detail that you think might make
the law better and more descriptive
sometimes can be a showstopper and the
best thing to do is to take it out so
legalizing any kind of nominal amount
for possession on the a part of an
individual who is not part of testing is
not something that this bill will do
anymore as as a practical matter I don't
think we're going to see uh police
arresting people for what's on a fenel
test strip um so as a practical matter I
don't think it it's an issue I think the
law enforcement Community um uh is
behind the effort of of saving lives I
mean this this is something uh a lot of
people in the law enforcement Community
are are the people who are administering
the lock Zone and Reviving people so so
I think in this I think what we're
really you know trying to do here is to
uh is to really work with the law
enforcement community and one of the
things that I know we wanted to talk to
uh the chair about was forming a
subcommittee um we've talked with uh
with Beth Sergeant um and kind of
reviewed in principle some of the things
that uh we're trying to do in the bill
and one of the things that uh that uh
she's indicated to us is you know a
willingness to work with us to kind of
get something through whether or not we
can get something through remains to be
seen uh whether or not we can agree on
something you know in final form I I
think it would be fairly easy to do but
I never want to I never want to suppose
um but the bottom line is is we got this
through this committee last year we got
it through the house um it's really
worth trying to do uh and uh and I would
urge uh
uh you know I
would just urge you to consider it and
support it thank you thank you
representative any questions
representative
Newman yeah I just have a question um so
people can have test strips they can
test with the test strips and then do
how I'm con concerned about how do how
does that get to the organization that
can test it do they bring a test strip
to the organization
I thinkes we do have people coming after
me who can probably describe that
process in in in better detail but there
there's more to it than just individual
uh drug users using test strips and
things like that there are also Public
Health uh agencies that are that are out
there um you know testing uh you know
testing drugs that are that are coming
in that people will bring in sometimes
so they're I think uh they'll be
prepared to talk a little bit more about
that
okay thank you right anyone else thank
you representative yep thank
you representative
Manion thank you madam chair members of
the committee for the record I'm Tom
Manion I'm representing Hillsboro one
pelum I'm in support of this bill uh
just wanted to be real brief I think the
representative from Durham hit all my
points about Public Safety I just wanted
to mention like the the entire purpose
of like uh alleged purpose of the War on
Drugs is to save lives and sometimes uh
these state laws get so hamstrung that
you end up like uh costing lives in the
process of like outlawing test strips
things along those lines that could do a
lot of good a lot good for the people um
so with that I mean I think all all my
points got handled but if you have any
questions I'm here to take
them looks like we're all set thank you
thank you
representative
cert hi um I'm representative Christine
cybert I'm from um Hillsboro um district
21 and um I just wanted to come up here
and voice my support I'm a co-sponsor on
this piece of legislation I believe this
is really important um I'm already proud
of what we were able to past um last
term and I really believe this is a big
huge chunk of well a huge part in the
toolbox a Big Tool in the toolbox for um
you know making a difference out there
on our streets and I believe the numbers
are showing for it they speak for
themselves so um I believe these changes
need to take place um to further um
allow for us to make a change within our
communities and to also show our law
enforcement our First Responders that we
you know we understand that that it's
been a struggle these past years so um
yeah with that said um yeah that's it um
and just please um support this
legislation thank
you that right thank you any
questions Dr Hannon
you're all
set look at that representative Pro nice
draw oh hurry let's hurry up and go
um Miss
Beal Dr Hannon we're just razing you
because you're a welcome me you
know welcome guest yes you may
okay if if you could um you're you're
both certainly welcome to testify and
you know kind of tag team with each
other if you could just please uh both
make sure you introduce yourselves and
then just let us know I'm you know in
support or of course oppose which looks
like support um if you could just please
state that absolutely um well good
afternoon everybody committee uh my name
is Liz Bley and I'm the Director of
Education and technical assistance at
the New Hampshire harm reduction
coalition
um I have been
there I have been there since 2020 I was
actually fortunate enough to be hired by
Dr NY herself um and in that time I have
had uh a lot of time working with folks
who use drugs directly folks who are
unhoused and folks who are in active
chaotic chaotic use um before being in
harm reduction I worked in treatment and
human rights um so very familiar but I
while the majority of my work is with
individual who are unhoused and in
chaotic use um I've also worked
alongside folks in long-term recovery
abstinence I've worked with family
members scared parents college students
working professionals doctors lawyers
businessmen um really anyone looking to
educate
themselves um I do all of the overdose
prevention and response training for our
organization um and in that I get asked
a lot of questions about what is
currently in our illicit drug Supply in
New Hampshire and how can gr Staters
stay safe um and I do hate the idea of
not being able to give anyone a exact
answer because unfortunately we just do
not have the information we can make um
anecdotal uh stories and evidence but we
don't have the direct data in front of
us
um um well of course we should be
worried about the presence of um
synthetic opioids and their various
analoges there are other adulterants
that are being found in the drug Supply
such as xylazine which is a tranquilizer
um and the one that worries me the most
is various kinds of bzo
diazines um who are using drugs um when
they are looking for treatment and
Recovery if they are not intentionally
using benzodiazapines but they come up
on their drug scream prior to entering
treatment um they can be barred from
that because they need to go through
detox and unfortunately we know in our
Granite State we do not have enough
detox Bots for folks so somebody who is
ready to go into treatment is not able
to do so because they need that benzo
dipene detox instead of just thinking
that they used uh
opioids um so I think it's also
important to note that this bill is not
legalizing any of the technology talking
about in the bill um what it I mean
anyone with an ebay account in the cash
can go and buy an ftri machine online um
I actually did the work and found about
12 pages of ftiri machines that if you
have a grand in your pocket you can buy
and you can start testing any
drug um but when we are able to put this
technology and the ability into the
hands of Public Health officials um it
does put us a step ahead in the illicit
Market um so a major worry is of course
college students um in 2023 the DEA
seized over 29 million fake pills that
contained
lanol um which was a 33% increase from
the year before um college students are
looking for press pills because they are
looking for things like Aderall um
oxycodone and those are usually not just
to quote unquote have parties with but
those are usually to um stay awake so
that they're able to study finish their
papers things like that Unfortunately
they are getting things that um have
opioids in them and they're unable to
reverse an opioid overdose if they are
by themselves um in other states that do
have drug checking policies uh they are
seeing things like gp1s or we know them
OIC in their drug Supply um so a lot of
compounding pharmacies do not have the
oversight that we need to be able um to
keep these specific drugs out of those
supplies and also for folks who are
using gp1s they would have the ability
in this bill to come to a drug checking
program and see what is in their
thirdparty glp1 so if they're buying
something off of an online pharmacy um
which the DEA last year in October did
release a public service announcement
stating that online pharmacy purchasing
for medications is risky um and can have
various analoges and completely unknowns
to us um
during my time in this work I've watched
countless
participants pass away doing uh because
they were not able to continue getting
their suboxin prescription which is
their medical assisted treatment or
methadone and this is because they miss
an insurance there's a Litany of reasons
um but because they're unable to get
that they then have to unfortunately
turn to a street supply of suboxin and a
lot of the times that does contain
Fentanyl and they unfortunately overdose
and pass away
um I think that this drug checking Bill
not only shows you what is in the supply
so you can proceed with caution um but
it also uh brings folks in who maybe
lost their prescription for suboxin
Methadone anything um who are still
trying to look for connection so that
they can continue to use the med um but
they're able to connect with public
health officials who can get them
connected to that prescription again so
that they're able to use that completely
safe Supply um we say a lot of the time
in syringe service programs that um you
know the needle is the point because it
is the point of Engagement for us to
bring folks in for them to trust us uh
folks who are using illicit drugs don't
have a lot of trust with providers um so
it's our job to provide that again to
them um and overall I would say that um
folks are are not necessarily looking
for the highest potency uh substance
they are looking to maintain and stay
consistent so that they're not sick um I
am someone personally who suffers with
chronic pain and while I don't use
opioids to manage it I know that if my
medication went away tomorrow I would be
unable to be a Community member I would
be unable to be a partner and a parent
um and the fact that people are so
terrified of opioid detox because of the
physical with draw pain should tell us
something um and of course I Leave
Myself open for any questions but I will
pass it over to Dr
Noti um well the the benefit of having
Liz go first was that she spoke to many
of my points here last for me um I'm Dr
Carrie Niti um I am a family nurse
practitioner in community health where I
conduct healthcare for the homeless um
in a mobile setting in mobile settings
um I'm also the chair of the nursing
department at the University of New
Hampshire and an associate professor
there um and my research focuses at the
University on um reducing drug rated
harms including overdose and infection
um I speak for myself as a member of
this community um and not necessarily my
employers um just to put that caveat out
there I did submit written testimony to
the committee um just a few minutes ago
through the portal I don't know when
that gets to you um but you'll have
other resources and links there if you
want to look more um into this I also
provided paper copies of a resource that
was developed um for New Hampshire
decision makers about two years ago or
began two years ago um and it I just
encourage you in your Public Safety
capacity to look at that understand more
about harm reduction um there's a
variety of strategies in harm reduction
um and if I can call your attention to
page 12 and 13 it outlines a variety of
different strategies and so I see New
Hampshire sort of as a late adopter of
many of these strategies but we have
comprehensive overdose education in the
lock Zone distribution we established
syringe services in
2017 um this committee um established
drug checking with rapid test strips um
in 20 what's the year now
2023 um and so what we're looking to is
this next level of comprehensive drug
checking um one of the one of the things
that came up about drug legalization and
past iterations um you know I hope that
this resource helps you to understand
but explain to your colleagues that
we're not we're not looking this has
nothing to do with Shooting Gallery safe
injection sites overdose prevention
sites which as a as an academic I will
say have great evidence but I don't want
any I don't want the conversation um to
um cut this bill off because there's um
more kind of fear mongering that has
happened in past sessions I commend this
committee and I um on all of this work
um in from introduction in 2023 to
retaining it and truly retaining it and
um you know pushing through some of the
language changes and things like that I
think um one of the points that Liz made
that's really important and is that
we're seeing more and more of an illicit
drug Market that are not opiates what
are weight loss medications um and these
are not coming from non FDA approved
sources they're being imported and so if
tomorrow suddenly we had an outbreak of
um seizures and sinkable episodes while
driving really and we found a common
cause you know we don't have the ability
in this state to address it rapidly in
ways that other public health um
departments do so I think the primary
driver of this should be wanting um to
prevent overdose and getting people into
recovery um and I will just share
personally this deeply affects me on a
personal level the third author on the
resource that we developed um
unfortunately um was having a lot of
struggles had been in long-term recovery
and um didn't show up to a meeting and
after checking on him I found one of my
best friends dead um from an overdose um
he had been um using um a substance in
order to sort of get him through through
it was not an opiate he had not um gone
back to using opiates ever um but that
the substance he was using did um was
eventually confirmed to have fentanyl in
it and that was his cause of death so he
would be here advocating for this exact
legislation um and I if he was here to
be here um so I think that the other
component and again there's more in the
written testimony but is just to talk
about what this looks like um I you know
it currently there's syringe Services
across the state not everywhere but in
these programs these are Anonymous
confidential Services where people
engage with Public Health Providers um
around getting safer supplies getting
education and testing for HIV HPC
referrals to treatment things like that
we see these programs as then just being
embedded in already existing programs
there's not going to be a drug checking
shop popping up um there's not going to
be anything like that and so the changes
in leg ation also really specify the T
the tailoring of this bill to um to harm
reduction programs that already exist
because as Li Liz noted we can all go
out on Amazon and buy one of these
devices it's that we are currently
missing Federal funding that is
earmarked for this service and these
Services um that are provided and are is
being obtained from many other states
because we don't have a legal route in
order to conduct this um one of the
other and I pass them all out so I don't
have it in front of me um but we've had
a lot of conversation in this Committee
in the past around the amount and what
constitutes a fatal overdose and we've
we've talked about that we have um these
little measurement spoons um that just
give you an example of the small amount
that is needed for comprehensive drug
checking and what we're finding in
states that are doing it is not this has
heroin and Fentanyl but this has heroin
Fentanyl Quil anti-depressants
Veterinary meds like some of these
samples have six different drugs and so
the the trends around rapid test strips
which are only developed for a specific
drug do not keep up with this and this
is passing this would enable us to
develop the infrastructure to develop
those resources we there's no budget
mark on this we're not seeking funding
for this project or program um this
would all be up to the New Hampshire
harm reduction Coalition and other
partners in order to obtain funding for
this with that I'm one other mention I'm
sorry um the other mention that we had
talked about before was xylazine
xylazine um is more and more um in our
drug Supply um in the last year it was
associated with was seen in 34 overdoses
and as you know the medical examiner is
well behind in analyzing samples so that
number is as of December I would
expected to be much higher once final
reports come out the issue from a
healthcare provider perspective with
xylazine is it is used as a Veterinary
tranquilizer when used um when snorted
or injected by humans um it causes um
massive ugly wounds that are similar to
Burns and take a long time to heal um so
people will not use medication will not
use substances with xylazine if they
know the presence another huge barrier
and a huge issue with xylazine use is
that our current um substance use
treatment infrastructure um does not is
not integrated with medical care and so
one of the qualifying factors for hey I
want to get into recovery please get me
in into inpatient is do you have any
open wounds so we now have a drug Supply
that's creating more and more open
wounds and it becomes a a key barrier to
people seeking recovery and treatment as
they can't get into those treatment
facilities because they're not a Medical
Care Facility they specifically focus on
addiction treatment and with that I'm
we're happy I I appreciate the
opportunity to be together um one of us
can probably answer most of your
questions um but both of us together is
is better so
um two is better than one so if if I may
I my my clerk was kind enough to tell me
when she passed this out this is this is
what you this is like what you guys were
ref referencing okay so is this little
spoon feel like I'm going to feed a
little bird or something um is is that
amount is that enough to a flat little
teeny spoon here is enough to do
comprehensive
checking okay thank you but is that if a
person H if a person would have that
much of one of these drugs that we're
talking about is that enough is that a
fatal dose so the um answer is probably
not the the this is 10 milligrams um so
there's two different pieces there's
potency of medication and there's weight
so this is a physical measurement of
weight or or of a substance um in
general for um for the potency all a lot
of what we've heard is within a grain of
rice within a little speck within you
know one grain can um lead to an
elephant to overdose I don't know I'm
making them up now but um there has not
been scientific literature that has
supported all of that there's a lot of
factors within that I know that it's one
of those potential um I can't say that
it's impossible but there's nothing
scientifically to support that this size
um accidentally encountered could you
know lead to an
overdose in general what you would be
seeing would be use of 100 times this
amount in a single use as far as like a
physical measure and we don't see
everyone using that amount overdosing so
did I get to your question or no I I
think so but I I actually have um a
couple questions I'm I'm actually trying
to learn something here so if you don't
mind bear in with me okay all right so
if if this my understanding from you're
saying though so that this is what you
could use this amount to
test to to test this drug right okay so
then
how what would be considered no
longer used for testing because I I
think Representative no was trying to
was touching on that but I wasn't able
to find it because there was a lot of
pages and it looked like the first page
wasn't really the bill it was more
statistics unless I didn't read that
right so I kind of got a little bit lost
with the number
so is there an amount that is that is no
longer considered to
be checking and it's actually the the
person has illegal drugs for illegal
reasons like where is that line yeah so
one of the changes from prior iterations
is that we're not we're not looking for
any exemption for people bringing drugs
to drug drug checking meaning like this
is for protection of Public Health
officials doing the testing the the
issue with why would there be an amount
is you know if we test rapidly um this
small size part of best practice is to
intermittently do confirmatory testing
in which we would have to take that
scoop and put it in a secure safe baggie
and send it to an external lab and so in
that time it would be in possession
possession by the drug Checker by the
you know person providing the service
Okay so that would go where where
representative n was saying about taking
the the amount out because there was
like no right or wrong or kind of got
con convoluted in with that that's not
so the one that's being taken out on
page that was one coming in foresting
okay but it is still in
there employees
So ba so basically there's there's not
an amount there's not an
amount or there is an amount I'm sorry
I'm sorry no I the I believe there is
not an amount but I'm just looking for
clarification on the terminology but
that was for the center right like
like to be able to do confirmatory
testing
it's where it's C out
okay
okay okay and then I um
one one other question that that I have
is
so so we're you know there's a lot of
talk about what what this is done and
the intention of that which is not lost
of me so my my question is though what
what where's the deterrent like is is
that part of this program anywhere cuz I
I haven't heard that but I don't I don't
know it might might be in here it might
just got lost on me because I was trying
like to find a where that you guys were
saying this stuff the deterrent to drug
use in particular you mean well
specifically right so like at the
schools you know like you have like we
did this last
year and I remember we passed it and
then I went to the school and there are
posters like everywhere that say about
you know there's no no safe experience
and like that like this should not be
relied upon but I feel like we're going
that direction so is there like
deterrence with this or what is that
public deterrent instead of check your
drugs is
there is there the deterrent Factor like
like the funding for that part or is is
this where is this the trend that
they're going to I'm I'm not totally
sure but I'll try to answer and then
tell me if I misinterpreted um I think
that part of part of the
um the way that we know these Services
work and harm reduction services in
general is that engagement in protecting
your health and safety is one step in
moving up in other ways of protecting
your health and safety including getting
into treatment and recovery and so in
general we know that harm Ru engagement
with harm reduction services like drug
checking and needle exchange um lead to
seven times greater um entrance sorry
it's in the pack somewhere but um you
know lead to seven times more um seven
times greater likelihood that people
will engage in treatment and recovery
and part of it is that we now
acknowledge that it's trauma is the
gateway to substance use um and that
within that and getting into
comprehensive treatment there's a lot of
self- stigma that people who use drugs
possess in um making those small steps
just with any other chronic condition is
really important to get them into
treatment um it's not people who engage
in drug checking sign into treatment the
next day it's more of a um General
understanding that's been developed over
the last 10 years in addiction medicine
okay does that help did that get there
yeah okay and then what would happen so
if a person were to if this drug is
checked and then it and it is bad like
is there any kind of a statistic that
that
says like what does a person do in that
situation right like oh nope that's bad
yeah are they likely to take
less
yeah I don't have an exact statistic but
what happens in many drug checking
programs across the US is that usually
participants after they get their result
go into direct counseling with a harm
reduction Specialist or um a public
health professional and they have a
conversation about what are the risks of
this substance now that you know
everything that it's in it um and a lot
of folks when that happens are able to
toss out their drugs um because they're
not interested in taking xylazine
they're not interested in having
benzodiazapines or anything baby powder
in their system um injecting that into
themselves so they're they're able to um
really I just totally lost my train of
thought but yeah I I think what we know
is that that we do see that you know
preliminary numbers have been about 50%
of people take measures to reduce their
risk based on those conversations that
Liz is describing so they don't use the
drug they use less of the drug they um
use in a different way that's less
likely to result in overdose wounds
things like that um thank thank you
thank you for answering my questions I
hope I didn't they were great questions
I tried to learn something there um or
representative pette
hi um can you just clarify for me who I
I guess I'm just not really
understanding who would have this
equipment in in their hands like who
would be you who would have this and how
are the people that need this
service utilizing it like how are they
accessing whoever's using the
equipment um I can try and say that uh
you know implementation would definitely
have to take a little bit for any kind
of drug checking program for the
Coalition but it would be Public Health
officials um it would be those who are
uh SSP workers har reduction Specialists
um and most likely we would uh share
this kind of Technology the same way
that we share um how folks can get to an
SSP or come and get those harm reduction
Services through Word of Mouth um
through various advertisements on on
social media newspapers all those things
but um it would be targeted at folks who
are probably already using the exchanges
and participating in harm reduction um
because it is something that they ask at
every single SSP how do I know what's in
my Supply because if xylazine in it I do
not want it okay and I will just say one
of the other populations of of Interest
into Target is around we see less
engagement in harm reduction services
around like say college age youth
um but we know that substance use is um
is happening and so this becomes another
tool when when people are you know
buying pressed pills in order to get
through finals um which yes I can
acknowledge we don't want them to do but
um they then engage in services that are
disconnected from their parents health
insurance disconnected from their school
that they may face repercussions it
gives them a confidential source to
engage with drug checking and also then
to support if they want to get into
treatment or they need to get into
treatment or taking other steps to
improve their
safety okay uh follow up sure follow up
um so we we have an engagement Center so
where I'm at like we have a shelter with
engagement Center so and there's harm
reduction Services there as far as I'm I
know so it would be somebody there that
works within harm harm reduction that
would be utilizing that equipment may
ask you are Manchester Manchester yes so
it would be the overdose um prevention
coordinator it could be Public Health
officials it could be something where
people are doing I mean they're already
doing HIV and hepatitis C testing in
collaboration with harm reduction
Services mobile van we have mobile Vans
um or we I don't I'm not with the
organization I just they let me hang out
with them um you know so it would be
those same services this wouldn't be a
new service it would just be another
tool in currently existing Services okay
thank
you representative
Newman it sounds like I mean reading
this um that you do portable drug
checking
now is that what I maybe I
misinterpreted yeah no not not in the
state um at least the New Hampshire har
reduction Coalition or myself as a
researcher we are unable to do that at
this time um we just work with
collaborate with a lot of folks in
Vermont Massachusetts that do this offer
this service regularly and and we do
offer test strips oh yes follow up
follow up so would is that one of the
benefits of this bill that it would
allow you to do that without Li take the
liability away is that yeah that's the
express purpose and and to be honest if
if we could I I think that it it's
really being able to fund these services
not through State funding but rather
there are federal grants um that we are
unable to obtain because it is not
expressly legal in New Hampshire
legislation thank
you there any any other questions we're
all set thank you very
much Miss fry
good afternoon my name is Kate fry I'm
the vice president of advocacy at new
futures um we are in support of HB 226
um I don't think I have much more to add
because all of my points have been said
but I will leave you with my written
testimony as well as um a document from
the new uh Network for public health law
that really talks about this issue and
it's a survey of other states because
we're not alone in this um a lot of
other states are looking to address the
um issue as well so this will give you
an idea of what other states are doing
um I do just want to underscore
representative musa's point I think one
of the main reasons that we uh New
Hampshire has been um successful as far
as like slowing down the um overdoses is
that we tried a little bit of everything
um and
uh we've been involved in things like
the Good Samaritan law um Narcan
distribution and we look at this as one
more tool in the toolbox and um although
we have an exception for xylazine and
fenal strips this is a comprehensive
drug checking program and we really
support taking the next steps because as
we know uh the people who put the drug
Supply out there they they're very smart
things change all the time we need to be
um equipped to be very um Nimble as well
um so I will leave you with my um
testimony thank you very much are there
any anybody have any questions we're all
set looks like we're all set thank
you Captain brigh is it is it
Captain Major D I knew I was going to I
knew
that can I have a can I have a do over
major br
I'm not titles but uh my name is Bill
brigh I am a a major with the state
police I oversee our Investigative
Services Bureau um and I've listened to
uh all the testimony today about this um
Bill and um you know as has been said
law enforcement is just as much invested
in Saving Lives as as everybody else
that has been at this table today um the
part of my uh purpose in being here and
part of my job I think is to um with my
experience look at a bill like this or
or a law and try and and try and think
okay is there a way that something like
this could be exploited by uh somebody
that has bad intentions um one thing
that I'll just say right now is as this
is written and I understand that there
may be an amendment uh coming so there
might be uh you know some answers to
some of these things but as this is
written it's it is very broad um
thinking about page four
specifically um you know at at the top
of the page uh line four it says a
person um I know it's been said that it
will be you know that this will only be
employees of these facilities um but the
way this bill is written right now it
does not specify that um it says any
person who possesses transports delivers
or provides uh a nominal amount and I
understand that that may be that wording
may be taken out but the question still
remains is how does somebody bring uh an
illegal dangerous narcotic drug uh
somewhere safely in order to get it
checked I don't have that answer I don't
know what the answer is to that um but
that is one concern that I have um you
know how how does that actually happen
um and would they be responsible if they
had more than whatever this amount is
that seems like should be established um
on the flip side of that if a uh you
know if an employee of the harm
reduction site takes in uh you know a
small bag from somebody that is more
than they need in order to do the to
check like what's the what's the
procedure what's the process for that
are are they disposing of the rest of it
are they giving it back I I just think
that there's a lot of questions that
that need to be answered uh in something
like this and it doesn't mean that um
you know we we wouldn't be willing to uh
you know to work with a committee if one
was established or um Representatives
that are that are trying to to work on
this I I certainly can't say that we
would support it um as of now we oppose
this bill um the way it's written um if
you look further down on page four um
sections uh four and five I mean it
we're offering subject to revocation and
probation parle or pre-trial release
subject to civil disciplinary or
administrative action subject to the
loss of one or more dependents subject
to the loss of housing or result in any
other punitive action or penalty taken
against the person um and the only
qualifier is that um you know that
they're engaging in any act authorized
under this section and I just think that
there's a lot of questions that need to
be answered um you know throughout this
process how how it actually takes place
before you could even consider offering
that that type of immunity um you know
and who who is vetting the people that
that will be handling the drugs to do
the checking
um all of those things are questions in
my mind and and I believe that they
should be questions in the committee's
mind if you're considering uh pushing
this
through thank you major
bra representative Sher
so I'm I'm curious uh exactly I guess I
need more detail about what your
concerns are on on page four on the
section entitled a person
may uh what are you worried about if
somebody brings with them more drugs
than are needed for the testing and then
the testing is done uh what are you
what's the specific worry you have well
narcotics that we're testing in this
case fentanyl most likely um and it
could be a multitude of other drugs are
extremely dangerous narcotics they cause
harm to uh the people that use them um
up up until death so that would be my
concern is if there's if there's an
excessive amount that's brought in
what's happening to that are we giving
it back to the person to take back and
use and I think that there's probably
some risk and liability in doing that U
what would you have happened
I'm sorry
followup I'm not challenging I'm I'm
just representative Sher please be very
careful just to ask questions and not to
challenge the
witness my question is what would you
have happen in that circumstance well I
certainly don't claim to have all the
answers to this problem that we have in
the state my solution would be no no
tolerance at all but getting there is
how do we get there that's that's the
big question law enforcement we do our
we do our job that we've been given to
enforce the laws that we have
established on the book so when there's
a new law I look at it how will this
affect the Community First how will it
affect uh law enforcement and how we
perform that job so to answer that
question my my answer would be is that I
wouldn't allow it is I wouldn't allow
that to happen I I don't see any place
where it would be acceptable for me or
anybody else to hand an amount of drugs
back to somebody and say um it's okay to
use this because it it just tested for
these
substances thank
you representative
Newman yeah I just have a question about
going on to his question where it
doesn't only say a person may it it
starts out with the title that says use
of drug J um checking equipment so I
imagine it would be a person that is
using drug checking Equipment May and
would that make any difference in what
what you've said just in the past I
don't know I like I say I'm not an
expert on on the all the wording in this
bill uh there may be some answers to
some of those things maybe it maybe it
doesn't um apply um but I just look at
this at from a law enforcement
perspective and if I read this uh bill
right now it looks to me like any person
may do these things and it doesn't it
doesn't Define that that's okay that's
an employee of whatever the harm
reduction site is how many employees
there are in the state where those you
know are located um or if it's just any
individual that has drug checking
equipment they're allowed to to possess
I I don't know the answers to all of
that I I just think that it needs to be
considered thank
you rep representative g
r i think my question actually needs to
go back
to I forget Dr No I know never mind for
you I don't think you can answer what I
want answer right now and that's
bouncing off of something they said
representative do you think that it's
something you could that you that you
could just go ask them no I think it's
everybody want to know can we they come
back after we finish this please thank
you we'll make exception it's an
important bill are there any other
questions for major
bra right seeing none thank you very
much thank
you is that
do you guys mind come do you guys mind
coming back up to answer a
question
okay I don't know if that's a if that's
a good thing for that scene
um if the if the committee wishes I
might be able to walk through where
these amendments hit to explain the
conversation that just came up well I
think we one thing we have to be very
careful of is we generally do not have
people come back up and you know ret
testify or do any cleanup if you will
and in all fairness that that really
wouldn't be fair because there a lot of
people that like to do that um but it
did sound like representative GA R had a
question that that kind of came up later
so I am making exception for her so if
we could just please stick to that so
that we don't have any problems going
down the line with that thank you
representative gther thank you for
taking my question um in in reading this
again and this this this piece here
about use of drug checking equipment
permitted a person may um as I remember
I thought it was uh the person that's
doing the drugs or purchase the drugs
was going to do the testing I I think I
heard something different today m that
um a health provider or someone like
that would be doing the testing so that
means that we weren't talking about
equipment that um the user would be
purchasing the test for themselves I'm
just asking yeah this would be related
to a service um so I I think the the
amendment comes to specifically Define
the scope of drug checking in page four
that is a followup to the bottom of page
three
which amends RSA 318 B2 to insert that
paragraph related to drug
checking and that specifically States
conducted by harm reduction programs
registered within New Hampshire
Department of Health and Human Services
so that was a change from prior
iterations to address these concerns
okay thank you very much I missed that
yes represent we're not opening we're
not reopening question questions up for
that we made an exception for for the
question
if if if you could they're I think that
they're probably more than happy
to right yeah thank you very much is
there anybody here that is wishing to
testify that has not turned into a paint
card right seeing none we will close the
public hearing for house B
226 and we have one more for this
afternoon
okay I am opening the public hearing for
House Bill
380 and recognize the prime
sponsor or a sponsor
if you don't mind just give a second for
settle in it looks like something's
being passed around thank
you I apologize it it kind of cut off
and didn't have any sponsors here and I
didn't want to call the wrong name
good afternoon you're all set good
afternoon chairman roads and um
honorable members of the criminal
justice committee um I'm Suzanne
representative Suzanne Vale and I am
from nashille ward 3 I am here before
you today with House Bill 380 and I'm
going to give you some testimony and
bullet points there will be other
testimony besides mine
in New Hampshire a qualifying patient or
designative caregiver enrolled in the
therapeutic cannabis program who sells
cannabis to an authorized un
unauthorized
individual is subject to the following
penalties under state law revocation of
their registry identification card so
according to RSA
126x colon 3 section
um six if a qualifying parent or
caregiver patient or care is found to
have sold cannabis to an unauthorized
individual the New Hampshire Department
of Health and Human Services revokes
their registry identification card and
the revocation removes the individual's
legal authorization to possess and use
therapeutic can cannabis and this is
under state
law also there's a first f pel penalty
under the controlled Drug Act and under
RSA 318-b colon26 any individual who
sells a controlled drug including
cannabis without proper authorization is
guilty of a class B
felony a conviction under this provision
may result in imprisonment of up to 7
years a fine of up to
$25,000 or
both the second felony is the one that
the bill addresses and that's specific
to the therapeutic cannabis program so
according to RSA
315b 26 9-a which is an additional
section A therapeutic cannabis program
participant patient or caregiver who
sells cannabis to a non-qualifying
individual commits an additional offense
classified as an second class B found
and the penalties for that
offense include imprisonment of up to 7
years and a fine of
$300,000 or both so summarizing the
consequences the revocation of the
registry identification card and two
separate class B felony charges each
carrying potential prison time of up to
14 years and
$325,000 in fines
so the double jeopardy effect is what
the bill is trying to address because
patients and caregivers are already
subject to General drug distribution
laws and those impose significant and
severe penalties for unauthorized
sales one of the arguments I have is
that the penalties for unauthorized
distribution are severe and they add
another felony specific to the program
that might discourage eligible patients
from participating due to fear of harsh
legal
repercussions um patients are vulnerable
and this is about the patients and I'm
here to advocate for them many program
participants have chronic illnesses and
this is just not something that's
occurring with them if they were to
somehow make a mistake and get caught up
in this felony that kind of time
is really expensive and I don't mean to
put a a cost on anything but as you know
I know from working with the Hillsboro
County
um system and working with their budget
that the medical cost of having somebody
with a chronic condition in the jail is
just skyrocketing and it is an issue
when you have people who are nonviolent
and they're in a non-violent type of
crime doing time time and being not able
to get their therapeutic cannabis they
would have
difficulty surviving
without a number of pharmaceutical
medications that are required to manage
these DEC these conditions in the
absence of using the therapeutic
cannabis so to get back on track
um patients can already sell in exchange
to another patient and
caregiver but this penalty assumes that
a person who is in the program is
transferring or selling cannabis that is
from the
program so an example of circumstances
that could happen for the patient is um
a certified person sells or transfers 2
ounces or less to someone who was
formally
certified but has recently had an
expiration of their certification where
the buyer knows they need they may or
not know they need to knew or
not a certified patient can come from
another state and doesn't know the full
extent of the rest restrictions in man
in New Hampshire and I dare say they
wouldn't expect things to be as serious
with the second F uh felony that's put
forth here for the
patient and then I have another example
if a patient gives the Cannabis to a
friend or family who has previously
acted as a caregiver that's another
complication I just believe that
patients don't always know exactly the
full extent of the um the penalties
involved and I personally did not know
the full extent of the penalties when I
became a patient and had I been I just
would feel like this kind of scrutiny is
excessively harsh and I would I would
really think about it twice um and to
you know it's safer to legally
take opiates to manage some of these
conditions and we don't want to be able
to say that
because it's not safer if someone faces
up to 14 years in prison and a
$325,000 fine so um finally I just
wanted to say that um
patients are already held accountable
it's very unlikely that someone who has
a chronic condition is going to
maliciously or deliberately transfer
what they have for cannabis there's a
lot of limitations on how much they can
possess in the first place and it is
expensive to participate in the program
it's not something that would be at all
economical for the person in the program
and then they also lose their access
completely
and faced some pretty stiff penalties so
I may have just said this in beginning
and skip this link uh lengthy speech but
House Bill 20
1295 was word for word the same as this
bill and it passed through this
committee on um a consent calendar I
believe it was unanimous and it went on
the floor and was passed by the house on
the consent calendar so there it was
unanimous as well so I hope that the
committee will take another look at this
and find that it is acceptable um and
I'll take any questions that you may
have thank you representative so
basically what you're saying is you're
you're okay with the first the the first
charge you just you don't like the
subsequent is that is is that like the
wrap up what you were saying yes and
that is a very good synopsis of what I'm
saying really to me it's it's just it
doesn't happen in other states other
states we're talking about a misdemeanor
and those that have you know states that
have other conditions such as they have
legal cannabis
already representative
Muse thanks for taking my question are
you aware of anyone who's been
prosecuted under the full extent of the
statute I am not thank you
good all right see no further questions
thank
you
Canon hello um thank you Joe Hannon
thanks um so I'm in favor of this bill I
do not think it goes far enough but I
think it goes far enough for our
purposes today um you've heard that it's
you're being punished twice for
something and it's something that's
considered um more dangerous than
selling something on the street I mean
someone is getting an unknown substance
that's not tested come from an elicit
dealer could be could be laced could not
be versus something that's a tested
product from dispens medical dispensary
I I think it's it's silly that you have
that comparison and also uh article 18
of our constitution penalties to be
proportioned to offense is the true
design of all punishment
I'm sure most of you know this but um
basically uh I I don't want to read the
whole thing but no wise legislature will
affix the same punishment to the crimes
of theft forgery and the like for which
they do those of murder and
treason
um you know we basically have laws in
the state for for a reason but if you
have a felony for uh aggravated sexual
assault you know someone has sex with a
13-year-old that person is going to have
the same penalty two times over for
selling medical cannabis that's not
proportion that's not Affair that's
that's unconstitutional and I even
believe that selling of a medical grade
cannabis now if someone's selling it to
a child I think obviously there's
different circumstances but say someone
is in the medical program and they get
caught selling it to someone who isn't
in the medical program because they
didn't get a card but wants to but
they're just afraid to get a card now is
that person really causing a society a
problem that New Hampshire deems it
necessary to give them an additional
second class B felony I think it's it's
wrong with whether you agree with
cannabis or not this has nothing to do
with that this has to do with uh what's
what's legal and constitutional and
what's fair and I don't think it
is thank
you thank you Dr Hannah are there any
questions all set looks like you're all
set thank
you representative cybert
hi
again um so um yeah my name is Christine
cybert I'm from Manchester Ward one um
Hillsboro district 21 um I was just
wanted to voice my support um for this
legislation um truly I think the reason
it seems to me the reason that we made
this um you know the medicinal purposes
for cannabis use um legal is so we you
know maybe don't get charged as harshly
for it um and so I see this as being
equal to having say like a mandatory
minimum for certain crimes like they've
tried to do in the past seem not to work
I definitely see it as a deterrent when
a lot of people find this um this uh
method or this this form of I guess
medication versus taking other dangerous
medications such as opioids that's
probably one of the number one reasons
it helps them with chronic pain um I
think that just throwing people in jail
is um especially if they are have
chronic pain they've gone through all of
the legal ramifications that or all the
steps that they need which is very
rigorous um it's also difficult quite
honestly for them to buy the amount to
be able to like sell that much that
would you know whatever um but either
way I think that stacking two different
felony um counts on them um there's
already like they said R rigorous harsh
penalties for such a thing um so I
believe there's enough barriers in place
where um this should definitely be a
good option so make everybody
happy any
questions Sor I kind of winged that I
didn't really write anything down
thank
you sorry the microphone's on
now good afternoon and once again thank
you for listening to me um also I would
like to let you know that represent
former representative kerk sends his
best but unfortunately he could not be
here uh he did however want me to hand
in some written testimony from
himself and as for the record my name is
Heather Marie Brown I am the alternate
chair on the New Hampshire therapeutic
cannabis Medical oversight board I serve
as the patient representative so it is
literally my job to represent the 15,000
plus patients in this state and I try to
do the best job I possibly can um quite
frankly um I will tell you that in my
opinion that little section of the
therapeutic cannabis law is literally
the exact definition of what
discrimination is the definition of
discrimination is unjust or
prejudicial treatment of different
categories of people especially on the
grounds of ethnic ethn ethnicity sorry
about that age sex or disability
therapeutic cannabis patients are all
individuals that have some kind of
condition disability or qualifying
Factor therefore that little piece of
the law literally discriminates it not
only provides a harsher punishment for a
person who is a therapeutic cannabis
patient but it completely puts them into
a category where they suffer
discrimination um I do work with people
that are not patients as well but that
would like to be patients and I can tell
you that one little section of the law
even though they have absolutely no
intentions of violating it whatsoever is
what keeps them from getting a
therapeutic cannabis card and still
seeking out ulterior incentives and ways
to take care of their own health um and
a lot of it is fear because it then
creates fear well if they can do this if
I sell my cannabis well what can they do
if they catch me smoking with somebody
or what can they do if they catch me
exchanging with another patient or what
can they do and it just it adds another
layer of fear
um to the whole equation and I don't
think that's right and I don't really
believe that that's the kind of message
that New Hampshire wants to send to some
of the most weak and V vulnerable
individuals that they have um I also
would like to tell you that therapeutic
cannabis is entirely way too expensive
for someone to have any interest
whatsoever in selling it to another
human being it just would not be
feasible or plausible or make any sense
whatsoever um so I believe that at the
time that this law was written and that
you know that was put in there that
there was fear around the fact that
cannabis wasn't as readily available as
what it is now now you can get it from
the streets you can get it from Maine
Vermont Massachusetts you literally I
can drive 30 minutes from my house cross
the borders and there are are eight
stores within a six mile radius of one
another um so I I think
that that section of the law is really
entirely outdated and you know again as
I said it's also
discriminative um and I believe that
it's time for it to be removed and I
believe that it's time for us to take
away that aspect of fear
from a wonderful program
so thank you very much if you have any
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank
you Mr
Simon thank you madam chair one more
time for the record Matt Simon Granite
Lea of
cannabis uh we do support this
bill uh long time ago uh from 2009 to
2013 I had the privilege of being one of
the leaders in the fight to pass the
therapeutic cannabis law uh the biggest
concern that we heard in this
legislature throughout that process from
opponents and Skeptics was the fear of
diversion uh there were some opponents
who tried to paint a picture that all of
these patients were really just seeking
cannabis for recreational use and that
they were fundamentally immoral people
who would want to purchase cannabis from
the dispensaries and then sell it on the
playground or to their friends and uh
there there was a lot of that talk uh a
long time ago so in response to those
talking points I repeatedly pointed out
that selling cannabis or even dispensing
it without sale is already a felony in
New Hampshire uh it's clearly spelled
out in RSA
318b
and that is a pretty big detriment or
deterrent that something is a
felony and we don't need more than that
that was enough unfortunately in order
to get the law passed in 2013 uh we had
to concede on that point and add this
extra felony to RSA
126x so it is just that an extra felony
without that felony I would argue that
police and prosecutors
have plenty of authority to prosecute
anybody who sells or dispenses marijuana
as it's called in RSA
318b to an unauthorized person so we do
not need this redundant extra felony in
oursa
126x and I do think it is a deterrent to
participation in the program because
when patients fill out the paperwork for
the program they have to sign a
statement that they know about this
extra felony and that they're putting
them they're setting themselves up for
this extra potential scrutiny so I hope
this will be the year that the extra
felony goes away happy to take any
questions thank you very much do we have
any
questions looks like you're all set
thank you very much thank
you Michael Holt
thank you very much Madam chair uh I'm
passing around information that you
likely already have it's a it's a a snip
of the criminal penalties for the sale
of cannabis just uh for reference uh for
the record my name is Michael Holt I'm
the administrator of the therapeutic
cannabis program with the Department of
Health and Human Services um I'm here
today uh uh to support um House Bill 380
um lot of my testimony will be uh
similar to what you've heard uh already
but uh if I would like to proceed um
three House Bill 380 proposes to remove
the an enhanced penalty for the sale of
cannabis by a registered patient or
caregiver um to someone who's not
authorized to possess basically to
another a person who's not a registered
patient or caregiver uh as you may know
in what I've just passed out New
Hampshire penalty is established in 318
b26 for a person convicted of selling
cannabis are based on the amount of
cannabis so less than 1 ounce the
penalty is three years in prison a
$225,000 fine 1 ounce or more is seven
years in prison or a $100,000
fine5 or more is 20 years in prison and
a $300,000 fine
if a registered patient or designated
caregiver is convicted of selling
cannabis in any amount they are subject
to an additional penalty they are
subject to the penalties that I've just
listed and an additional class B felony
with the following additional penalties
7 years in
prison $300,000
fine so the legislative intent for this
extra penalty um perhaps made some sense
in 2013 when the therapeutic can Canabis
law was first passed uh at that time
there were no legal means for adults to
purchase cannabis outside a State
medical
program no State at least in the
Northeast had legalized cannabis for
adult use uh Colorado and Washington had
legalized it in 2012 uh so in 2013
medical access to cannabis was believed
to be a primary source and cause of
diversion uh the concern that patients
would purchase it legally from their
medical dispensary and sell it to
recreational users um at a profit uh at
that time uh pricing of medical cannabis
was intentionally set um at black market
prices to discourage um uh diversion and
in 2013 access to therapeutic cannabis
in New Hampshire came with great
responsibility uh not to divert it um
and it was believed at the time of
writing that an enhanced penalty would
do the trick to to deter any potential
diversion fast forward to 2025 um the
situation is very different legal
cannabis is legally sold everywhere um
in uh in New England um except New
Hampshire and Pennsylvania um in terms
of the Northeast New Hampshire adults
have easy access uh to Legal cannabis
within uh with a short drive across
state borders in any direction um and as
you know cannabis brought back into New
Hampshire legally bought in another
state has been decriminalized up to
amount of three4 of an ounce um because
of this
Regional legal access the risk of
diversion for profit from therapeutic
cannabis patients has been greatly
reduced some might argue it is
practically
non-existent um medical patients no
longer have special access to this uh to
this uh to to cannabis um and and as as
has been testified um diversion by
patients doesn't make any Financial
sense because adulted recreational
Cannabis sold in other states
cost less than therapeutic cannabis
costs here in New Hampshire there's no
Financial incentive to divert uh so to
be clear selling cannabis is a crime
it's still a crime um it would be still
be a crime after this bill passes if
this bill passes for everyone in New
Hampshire uh the penalties in 318b 26
would remain this is an old law it's no
longer necessary uh register patients
who happen to make a poor life choice or
a mistake uh and are caught and
convicted of selling cannabis to someone
not authorized to possess it should be
treated the same as someone who's not a
registered patient um I want to thank
you for the opportunity to testify and
um I'm happy to take any
questions you're welcome thank you for
coming in today are there any
questions looks like you're all set
thank you very much thank you more you
is there anybody else here that would
wish to testify
on House Bill 380 that has not turned in
a paint card seeing none close the
public hearing and that is uh concludes
our business for today
and I will see you all tomorrow
morning
e e